Hi. Four three, two, one
fresh from fucking dope.
I want to learn the motherland.
You were in the motherland for days.
The mother land,
now it's the motherland is sort
of a one quarter of my heritage.
The capital of fighting, that's for
sure. [inaudible] is an Irish name.
I don't know what if you know that lad,
is it really? I'm one quarter Irish.
Everyone out there,
I'll bring Grogin out him like,
what do you want me talking to him,
man? Oh, can you try Rashawn shit.
Fucking animals, Bro. Favorite place
I've ever been. Really? Yeah, man,
it does a savage. They're just, they're
not even saying that they're savages.
They're super friendly. So friendly.
Not that people were, you know,
in Australia or London or Manchester
weren't, but in Dublin they were like,
I was like, damn, I don't want
to leave man. Look, I loved it.
I was thinking yesterday
when I was watching,
I'm like Conor McGregor workout
and like all the people,
we're surrounded him
while I was working out,
you know when those open
workouts real weird. Yeah.
It was the only standing around
hitting the bag and he's,
he seems to just be doing his work,
doing his normal work, you know,
hitting the bag. But there's just a
circle of people like right there,
he's a lion. Oh Sally, that
he can't even move. No,
he can't like dance around.
He can't back up too much.
He's just right in front of that bag and
he's got to pretend those people aren't
there as he works in the show. Right.
It's just a show to hype the fight more,
I guess it is in the box. And Pierce
Make Fun of them cause movement.
They won't make fun of him if he
lands the way he did it in that clip.
Opale that's what I'm saying.
When he landed that straight left,
but lamb and snap Paulie's head
back. I'm like, Hey Paulie,
why didn't you talk about that?
He's says he's been on a tear.
Just adds all really significant.
But if a guy like Conor McGregor does
that desk straight and clean and sneaky
announces to m and a little off speed,
like a little off speed and the
initial part of the movement,
then he drops it in. Bang.
It's like snake like left hand,
like he's getting super comfortable.
If he can do that to Pauline Mala noche
like whatever you say about those clips.
All we know is that that's,
that's what we've seen.
We've only seen these little short
little clips like white here.
Watch this left hand, which
I sneaks this in. Boom.
Sign
on to that left hand is fucking
legit cause it's super legit.
Here it is again.
Why is this?
Yeah Dude, that is down the
pipe. Caught what you want.
I mean granted that's the 12th round but
still parked at the time world champion.
I don't know what round though
was. I don't care. I don't care.
You can do that with that kind of speed
to Pauline Mala Naji and time that like
that. That's slut. Look, you can't
sleep on him. He's got magic.
Doesn't always work.
That's what does know.
His work is kind of new
ideas has a little magic to
different type of magic,
but that you know in that fight,
Nate Diaz had the magic and it was
just not Connor's nine. But the rain,
which was college, no, not
really. No, I don't think it was.
I think the rematch was bolted.
They're night.
I think if you really want to look at
that fight, honestly the second fight,
I don't think you see a winner.
The only thing that I think you could say
makes Connor winter is that he dropped
Nate but Napleton,
but Nate was saying that he went down
with punches anyway because he was hoping
Connor would follow him to the ground,
which may or may not be true,
but it is a good strategy if you have
a wind watching sport way too long that
Nate's got a wicked guard we can decide
like to get like when he gets clipped
just to go down with it and to try
to bring him to the ground. Look,
Fabrizio does that for resale for
doom. Absolutely does that. He does.
He'll do it right. Getting dropped
in the face with a left hand. Well,
it was a very good shot,
no doubt about it.
But the idea is if you get hit with a
good shot, you can decide to go down.
Then you can decide to bait
a man three times in a row.
I think you have to take
it into consideration as a
possibility once am I need a
rolling B every time he would try it,
try it. You're right. We never have,
he doesn't have these tendencies. Doing
all the same salary really fucked up.
Nate in a fight is Josh Thompson.
Josh Thompson head kicked
him and every other fight.
Even when he's gotten beat
up like the dos Anjos fight,
he's got his legs beat up and dos
Anjos definitely want a decision.
Nate didn't get fucked up and stop
stopped. He's never got his ass whooped.
Josh is the only one stopped him.
Yeah, but he still never got it.
Like is that never gets asked what?
Well, let me know what you could say.
The dos Anjos fight was kind of a beating
that they'll sign geosys kicking the
shit out of his. He still coming forward
like stood upset. He never been broke.
You can say that they've never broke as
well. 100% even in the Thompson fight.
If they let it go,
he probably would have
recovered eventually if he
didn't go on car. Correct. See,
I think the,
the real test of who's better,
Conor McGregor and Nate Diaz is if they
fight at 55 and the trilogy fight cause
70 it's a tossup. You know, Nate, one
one, Connor one one that's whatever.
They're both not fun at 70 they go to 55
you have your true I think winter there.
Well, you know what I mean? I like
native 55 me too at her anyway,
he gets real lean.
Like in the Michael Johnson fight comes
to destroy Johnson shredded at the man
was just check, check, check, check.
I'm assuming that's what he's waiting
for because they've often fights. Right.
But he's just waiting until
that big Conor payday,
I think him and his brother were smart.
You know, there are huge cultural icons.
They can go places and get paid and um,
they're still in the mix for, you
know, whatever weight class 155 or 70.
If he wants to be suspended for a
long, very long, just kind of pay.
He's just got a pay does not. Yeah.
It's not a suspension anymore. It is,
is he owes them $100,000
and he won't give it so,
so gangster one 65,
I think he gave him like 65.
You can argue that though, like
remote with common are like, listen,
you're suspended. You're not fighting.
You got to shoot a forestry mail
that day as soon as shoot or bullying
commercial and pays 175,000 comment. Cool.
Just not find Vegas though it.
Yeah, I know. No money. Uh,
just a 15 second tweet and then we'll,
we'll let you fight here.
But you got to realize when
a guy's throwing a monster
energy drink and they're
thrown water bottles, this is, I don't
like to say this, but this is true.
Does a big part of what's going on there.
That is theatrical [inaudible] that's
no different than pro-wrestling called
cell and a fine, it's called salad.
A fight and that's they're doing,
they're throwing shit at each other.
Sound effects.
Do you think he's really trying to incite
a riot like you know, occasionally, yes.
Like the DC John Jones. Thank that
was legit. Different animals animal.
And how much of that sell the
fight? The UFC was like, oh,
let's just keep that in nonstop.
And then they're like,
we do not approve of this. This is
ridiculous. Show it one more time.
Show it again one more time. I love
that though. That's clip ever. Yeah,
they did. They capitalize. I don't know
if they did on the John Challenge saying,
you know I did cocaine a week before
I beat your ass. No, they didn't.
That was the greatest light.
The most savage line f her ever.
Jon Jones is no joke.
And Jon Jones like in shape,
but something approved like
he did against Carmine's.
Scared so scared when he
kicked him in the face.
My word about how the fact that he says
the exact perfect thing after the fights
over. Correct. About Daniel or mark about
Daniel's. It's just, you know, I mean,
it's still real for the
first time too. Yeah, I be,
he probably felt so much gratitude,
you know, when I said to him like,
I didn't know what I was going to
say to him, but when I said to him,
you made it back.
That's how I felt like,
not just that he made
it back to the title,
but like you made it back from the
dark lands, from life, from the back,
running away from a hit and run accident
with w who knows what the fuck you've
got on you. You know, all that made
it backs understatement. I mean,
homeboy and people never stopped
cheering for him. Very interesting.
You know, people were mad at
DC who DC, but then John Jones,
his fame went up. Pregnant lady
broke her arm and ran from the scene.
It's crazy. I don't
understand. First of all,
I don't understand how you could not
be a fan of DC. I don't understand it.
I don't understand. There's
nothing wrong with them. Like what?
What would you not be a fan of?
The guy's a fucking animal. He's,
he won the Strikeforce heavyweight.
GRANDPA defeated at him. I mean,
he's throwing around Josh Barnett,
who's a 255 pound gorilla,
Daniel Cormier hoisting spiked.
He's macho man. I mean, the guy gets
into MMA fairly late in his career,
right?
Massively successful amateur wrestler
gets into MMA and says running through
people has a fight.
The first fight in the UFC as against
frank fucking mirror beats the pants off
of a former UFC heavyweight champion
your first fight in the UFC and beat the
breaks and beats the brakes off.
I mean,
it wasn't satisfied and it's
still whooped his ass. Yeah,
I mean got the under hooking did work.
It's just people like people got at him
for the Anderson Silva fight that he
like held. Anderson Silva
[inaudible] me a little bit too.
Like I can see why fans like come on man.
Anderson Silva two day notice or
whatever the hell it was. Come on.
But Harrison front kicked him in the
gut. Remember that? Yeah. Her, her layers
especially,
you'll see 200 such a big card and there's
so much hope when you don't perform,
you're like, come on man. And with
DC, I think the biggest thing is,
and it's not his fault,
he's better than everyone in the world
at light heavyweight except for John
Jones. So when John left and he had the
title, people are like, that's fake.
That's not his fault. It's not
his fault. John, be mad at John.
Could you imagine if you could get
Daniel's brain inside rumbles body?
Oh my God, that doesn't happen. Right?
Isn't that interesting
how that doesn't happen?
It's like John John's is the closest
thing to guy who's got insane talent,
but he also has like, almost
like dad, Darryl Elkins,
Darren Elkins, rather. Um, the Darren
Elkins mentality of like never quit. Like,
remember when he got his arm?
Hyperextended but if you don't feel bad
by [inaudible], his arm was fucked up,
never tapped. You know, like when
he fought the Gustafson find,
he wasn't in shape at all and
went five of five hard rounds,
which is two matters,
the best fight ever.
And was winning the final
round or about what?
Against Ryan Bader who ran painters
fricking good I think at times. Right?
Four or five in the world
doesn't even really train.
They said they saw him like two days
and went in there and cradle him like a
baby and whooped his ass in
the first round. Beat his ass.
I mean it's just talking
about a different animal man.
Cause he's a different animal.
But he's also got this mindset like he
has a real champions mindset or it's like
rumbled doesn't really like to fight.
He's just super good at it.
You don't think rumble likes it?
He says he doesn't. Oh he says,
he says that he says he
doesn't want to fight anymore.
Since it was my brain trauma.
He doesn't want to be rolling
around with what you're saying.
I got that confused with DC.
No, we are rumbles. Rumble.
Rumble is like the scariest guy ever at
two oh five when it comes to striking,
like who fucks ever been
scarier than rumble?
Nobody owes to Meyer Pretty
Goddamn cold right now. Right? Who?
He's scary right now. Technique.
Just fucking, oh, he's got, he's got,
he's gay. Oh, to Jimmy Madeline. He was
like, you're, you're a power puncher.
Do Cool. Check this out
too. Interesting cat man.
Interesting cat number three was
e three in the world he'd, yeah,
he knocked out Sir coon off.
Right and knocked up Meesha and then just
Merck's Jimmy Manoa in for like walked
through and,
and called it too.
It's like I'm knocking out in the
first minute or so. I'm can go do it.
Jesus cry and Jimmy didn't even land
anything like inside this clinch.
She catches him with that hard left hook.
These, he's got hammers for Phis to bro,
but he's like rushing it. Hi Allie.
Did you know what I'm saying?
Like I calculated like a John or you know
like the jds where he's sitting back,
he's got confidence in his power.
I'm sure none of it is brick
hands to your shake his hand.
Oh apparently go Brock Lesnar style that
does that work against the gusts spin
and Jon Jones is the question out soon
because I'm a fucking might be champion
the world just 70 Twitter followers,
light heavyweight champion
of the UFC. He's like, fuck
just what you do bro. You
know what he's, he's, I dunno.
He's changing his nickname to know time.
Is that what he changed his nickname
too? That's an awful short time. No time.
Because like he points to his wife,
he was like pointing to his watch at the
time. That was like his move. Oh yeah,
no time. No time. Like after the fight
he was like pointing to his wife.
She's like, this is my new
nickname. I have no time. No time.
He's nasty man.
He's very nasty.
He's got real legit 100% one punch power.
And when he clipped here, wait clips
guys, you can see they're like, oh shit.
And he goes bananas on him. See, I think
they should do Gusman Jones. Right.
And then do those Demira verse DC.
We'll have to see,
wants to fight again. We're going to see.
He said he did. You see what he does?
He goes, not only I'm going to fighting
him, I'm going to fight John Again.
Give it upset.
My heart can't take it.
You think you should give it up and
it gets right back in there. Why not?
It was a good fight up until the moment
John Landa at high kick. I agree.
I don't think he ever beats John.
I think he might be right,
but you might be a problem and
then it gets even crazier. But see,
I don't think he's ever going
to get the fight either.
I don't want to see it again. It
certainly could. If he beats a few people.
You certainly could because you could play
clips of that fight and say, you know,
he was doing very well, not
fight. I think John was winning.
I think John was landing more volume
and he was mixing things up really well.
That was ring Russ to let,
that's John kind of feeling things
out and then once he got comfortable,
oh this is what we're doing. He didn't do
shit. He didn't seem ring rusty at all.
I see. I smooth right from the
beginning, a little smooth, but I,
I do think DC's pressure and stuff like
that and just getting under his feet and
once he did, then he started to tee
off and take over, I think. Yeah,
he found his rhythm and he found DC's
timing. You know, you started the,
and then they settled in a little bit too.
Once they get onto the Sacramento and
both guys had exerted quite a bit of
energy,
hit each other quite a few times and
that third round and then you're going to
be that, that I think those
DC's best chance to beat them.
Now John's off to the races now. Good
luck with no time. There's those de Meyer,
there's guests Finn, then
Brock Lesnar, yet Steve Bay,
I think it goes to heavyweight.
Who knows, man. I mean if,
if they work out some sort of a deal where
he fights Brock Lesnar, well, oh God.
Come on Joe Course Stairwell. When he
called them out at the end of the fight.
I was like,
oh my goodness,
I saw Brad Watch Salt Brad Pitt shadow
box on Instagram or you better be careful
son, UFC gonna reach outside
and you see a problem.
You got to watch your pit would
fuck cm punk show me too though.
They'll Brad Pitt from snatch,
you know? Also I think Brad Pitt,
that guy lived with Angelina Jolie
for like 10 years. No much rage.
He must have Penn doesn't hate him.
Was Johnny Depp just or talk of organic
sustainable farming and adopting new
kids. Random kids. Who the fuck
is this? He just wants to
smash you. Just go in there,
fuck him up. Smash. Just
pit smashed on bitches.
Just so angry at, listen to that
crazy lady he lived with for decades,
made him an alcoholic.
Do you hear it?
That was a raging alcoholic and
she was a kid. He was, I love kids,
but there's a new one every goddamn day.
Like I can't keep a kid after kid.
Oh my God. Yeah. I mean that's just my
opinion. He would slap a bitch. I mean,
maybe she's a wonderful person. I
mean, she obviously is very charitable.
Maybe she's exhausted, exhausted.
That's the vibe I get. Hey Brown,
she took,
she had a vile of Billy Bob Thorton's
blood that she carried around her neck and
Billy Bob, I'm not hating on you, and
she was in his fucking beautiful. I get,
I can make time this then I didn't
get how people make mistakes.
He could let around your neck.
Hey, what are we going to do?
We're going to live for sure.
Shanique in bed for guy like him.
When's the guy like him get a girl,
girl like that.
The universities have to like collide.
That's will be some worm hole.
You've got to talk to
some such match shit.
She puts her your blood around her neck.
He's a bad motherfucker though.
She was strong. Dick game. She great.
Your blood around her neck, Joe.
I think they both did. They
were each other's blood. Yeah.
That's what they're doing.
They're both wearing each other's blood.
That's another level.
Not only that,
but here's the real problem with
it. You tell people about it. Yeah.
It just kept to yourself,
man. Telling people about it.
Tell people it's dragging blood or
some shit. When you tell it. It's hers.
A little weird. Well I think anybody
that's as good an actress as she is,
she's a really fucking good,
amazing. She's really good.
I think you have to have a
good percentage of crazy.
Like it's gotta be way up there
in the 90s actors too though.
I mean even for men like the
men actors who were really good,
like day to day Lewis motherfucker was a
shoe cobbler for six years just to play
like some 30 minute roll.
It's got legs.
He went full fucking cobbling working
as a cobbler right now and like London
assumption.
No,
I think he lives in Connecticut and
he makes furniture or some shit. God,
you never go full Louis Man. But
that's cause he's, he's legit.
Like that's really who we is.
Like an actual artist.
But that's why he's so interesting.
It's like his art or what
his mind goes towards.
It's not dictated by finance.
It's not dictated by the, the,
the box office success
you could potentially APP.
It's literally dictated by
what he's interested in.
He's interested in making shoes.
He's just going to make shoes like
you're not going to see him cast this
superman like he's like, that's not
his art. You know what I'm saying?
Admired the shit out of that because
people, we compromise all the time.
People are always compromising.
You're always like, you know,
trying to suck up to the boss,
hoping you get that raise or you know,
you're compromising what you say around
the office because you know you're at
this level of the company ladder.
These people above you that would get
upset if you talk about the things we'd
love. Someone just free
and authentic to like what?
Play Batman the fuck Outta here.
Fuck away from me. Yeah.
Ben Affleck was like,
I got this Ben Affleck's like this
is perfect. This shit is perfect.
Who his other homeboy as
surprise play Batman. Well,
a Christian Bale was the best Batman in
my opinion is just his voice bothered me.
Ooh, it was a little fake, right? Yeah,
but it me, he got to go
comic book a little bit and
that's how you go comic book.
But anyway, why would it change
his voice? Why don't the suit,
he's got to make a fake voice.
You're going to make a fake voice so
people don't recognize your Bruce Wayne.
Yeah.
Don't you at least have like some mouth
thing catchphrase or some people would
know that would be dope
if you covered your face.
Like why do we need to see the
Lower Chin of Batman? First of all,
I don't think that's a good idea for
protective measures. He lead you.
You have a white button where the most
vulnerable part of your faces. Strange.
Like if I came in here and yeah, what's
that? If I came in here to bat suit on,
if you had the Batman seat, I'd like,
oh that's Joe. You know what I'm saying?
Like it's not a very good fucking Cobra.
The Chin part is terrible because like
that's the part you'd want to punch and
it would be like so white. It's like
if you're in a fight with that man,
just shoot for the chin. You can't
miss it. It's like if you're,
if you're hitting focus pads, he gave
his to like looking at this one spot.
It's like you have camouflage on
everywhere. No spot. You get knocked down.
You looked at it.
I ever like,
you're going to not protect
the most volatile. How about
just open, open though?
Nose part up to like, you knows
get smashed. That's so crazy.
That's so strange.
Why don't they,
I mean do they really have to have that
same suit? Look this up? I don't know.
No one's ever figured it out until us.
It's like Bruce Wayne from Batman in the
fucking like Dan and Dan and none the
Batman. At least he didn't have like
a protective suit on Adam last night.
You just had that hanging over his eyes.
He was just in disguise
like this Batman Index,
this Batman is gotten to the point
where he's in his arm. Basically.
It was an armored suit. Right. And
meanwhile he doesn't cover his face.
Oh, it was superman. You covered a
little bit of it. He's going to see,
he's basically a night there. He
want, he's going to war. But Superman.
Do you know how God damn stupid
data's and doing work? You kind of,
what I watch it kind of looked to SAS
superman. It's from another planet.
He can fly so fast. He makes the
world spin backwards. He makes time,
goes backwards.
He's a master of time.
He can cut things in half
with his eyeballs. He's got
laser, she's out a drive.
Pick his dumb ass up and carry me as
high as he wants and let them go. Yeah.
Movies over could bring you to the
sun. Yes. Throw you into the sun.
You fucking talking about
Hollywood shit on my face. How,
how crazy is that?
The idea that gravity is so dense on
Superman's world that when he comes to
earth he can fly and then the atmosphere
is so different than his body's
bulletproof,
but he looks just like us.
But the atmosphere wasn't,
people don't understand if you went
somewhere and if you're like from Earth,
right and then you go to somewhere
that has like less gravity like space,
like those guys to go
to the space station,
they are fucked up after a year.
Like it doesn't make them stronger.
It makes them weaker, weaker, their
bones shrink. Like they'd come back man.
And they had their bones atrophy.
Like they lose bone density,
they come back and they're healthy.
That's why there's this only surmount
of time you can be there. Right.
I think the longest is right
over a year. Yeah. They've,
I think they've like hit the new record.
I think I got hit the new record
but I had um, Cham what is his name?
Commander Chris Hadfield
had him on the podcast.
He was fascinating and he was describing
what it was like coming back from how
long was he up there for? I
think it was a year. Right?
You just came in to clicking like
Schmiegel or he just said when you land he
said 879 gasp. Oh my goodness.
I'm rushing up there.
He's been for five missions.
Okay. Those Russian came,
the man has spent the most time
and space when he surpassed.
So that's like overall time ever.
That guy just keeps going to space 2.2
years overseas. Like six trips though.
That too is trying to get away from his
wife. He fat. That's five years. Yeah.
Russians, it you to take it
another level, don't they?
I think you'd have to say like what's
the longest space mission or something
consecutive 15 days the most.
Huh.
But that was 2015 I believe
commander Hatfield was after that.
Still not dose time. I might not be
right about that, but either way.
Fucking a hundred days shit from what I
want to do a hundred days in the woods.
Dude, I don't want to 10 days on the
road, 10 days. I was super lonely.
I felt like I was in space.
Yeah, we were talking about that.
Like you've got to bring friends.
Big,
big part of it and it's good for
the friends too. It's a, you know,
get guys a Gig like that where they can
open up for you in front of a packed
house. That's cool. Venues also warm up.
The crowd liked I'm going out to eat
just like, which is fine, you know?
You know when,
the only time I ever did that in the
last like 10 years was when I was helping
Collin out when a warm
the crowd up for Collins
and I was like this is so weird to go
on stage. Just go onstage and say hi.
Not have someone in front of you. But
it's a good, it's good exercise. Yeah.
Cause you got to get them into, you
know I brought me right back to how it,
when I used to do it, it was like
right away start thinking about how I,
when I first started out,
that's most of the shows that we can be
the opening act like in Dublin doing a
shot two in the afternoon. It
was crazy. I mean just crazy man.
But the why'd you guys do it
like that? That's a, that we,
they booked on such short notice.
That's the way I'd do that too.
And I do another one at
uh, like seven. Oh Wow.
That's just the way they wanted to do it.
Cause I'll have like an how did you get
away from those savages after the show's
over? I had stayed. I like I, I did a
meet and greet with everyone and then they
bounced. They were like, Hey, let's get a
pint. I'm like, which one? Like up there.
I'm like, see you there. And not
just like, chill. I drank so much.
Guinness is ridiculous. They'll put you
down. I loved it, man. Loved it. Yeah,
there it's a different world over there.
It really is Ireland, England, you know,
um,
they,
they have a long history of tradition
that we don't really understand, you know,
just, just what their culture's like that,
you know, the language and the history.
You go over there, you're like, oh, this
pub is 700 years old. Like what? Yeah.
I went to,
it was supposed to be the oldest pub in
Ireland and there was bullet holes from
fighting, you know, the rebels. Wow.
They were in there and his family
owned since day one. And the,
the owner was this dude
who is old as fuck now,
but he was born and raised upstairs.
He lives there now.
He's the only one still
alive. We're, they're just
all night with Patty Hooligan.
It was great. It was great. It
was so awesome. Just sipping. Wow.
Eating Chris Shit, my pants afterwards.
But in the crisps or potato chips, right?
Yeah. I call him Chris. I'm from the
you call football, football or soccer.
I see American football
cause I have a big day.
Talked about football and go American
flag. Otherwise you're screwed.
You're superstar. But you know what's
best for me. Joe Is like I did, uh,
what was it, like 10 shows and
uh, four days or something.
Like 10 shows in five days
or something like that.
And I wish I could do it more here. It's
just the wraps for me. Reps. Oh yeah,
that's what we're, we're
talking about comedy club.
Weekends are so good, so good.
Like, uh, when I did a salt lake, Salt
Lake City, when I did a, a wise guys,
I was like, man, you too. I
really get to feel it again.
Like what it's like to do for
one hour shows in a weekend.
It's like he gets leu timing
down and then tag lines.
They started like adding on.
He started coming up with new ideas to,
what is it about coffee that gives
you flam even just fucking really,
this is just a cold brew,
a caveman cold brew and those nitrile
cropping or dairy or anything.
I'm always ready to cough or
clear my throat and it's annoying.
I feel like it's an older thing. Nah
Man, it's always been that way with me.
With Cox, it's an older thing.
Hold guys, get all Fleming's,
get my cane. I drink a shit load
of coffee and my voice is good.
You know when it is for whatever weird
reason when like if a guest is talking,
like if you've got a good story and
your story goes on for a few minutes and
then I don't talk for awhile,
it all builds up.
You have to jump and secret. Yeah. Cali.
So He's trying to avoid coffee.
I told county, you need this,
you need to get your fucking
throat checked out. I mean,
he's been doing it since I've known him.
We just didn't hostile stop
AIDS sucking dicks. I'm
so about football, man,
I wanted to ask you about this because uh,
we were talking recently about this guy
who were tired super young. He's like 26,
right? Some dude just retired from
the NFL. Yeah, I'm dying, Joe.
Is that what you're asking? No,
no. What I'm asking is like,
you as a guy who's played football
and it's a guy who sees all this, uh,
the shit that's coming out now,
do you think there's going
to be a change in the game?
Do you think he's going to be like
less people that are signing up for it?
That that's what they say and they
say like with the youth leagues now,
they're like, oh, we're
teaching them how to hit proper.
But it's like there's no such thing.
There's no, it's, it's not real.
Like that's a fun campaign and
stuff like that. But you know,
it is America ever gonna get rid of
football because CT, no man, I just,
it's part of the game. It's literally part
of the game. You know? Wait, wait till,
wait till the UFC numbers come out.
You're going to be surprised.
I have friends now. I talked
to him like, oh my God, man,
do you not realize what's going on here?
And so once that comes out,
now we know it with boxing
and mixed martial arts,
like of course there's going to be brain
trauma guys getting punched in the head
with football. People are like, what?
But if it's literally part of the game,
it's just, it is what it is. Now is the
juice worth the squeeze and football?
The argument is it
depends for your health.
If you're coming from nothing and it
pays for your college, you make you know,
$40 million. Your family, your family,
their family set for life. God,
that juice might be worth the squeeze
depending how bad you're going to have it,
if you can get to that
level. Correct. Yeah.
I mean there's probably a
lot of guys who wash out.
I know what to more likely
than not, they watch out. Yeah,
I knew I'd do who washed out and he was
really fucked up the point where like he
was seeing shit there wasn't there.
He would go out into the yard
and start talking to himself.
It's such a bummer man.
Everyone responds different.
But they say the biggest thing,
and you know,
I guess it's the biggest thing because
I played football since I was what,
six years old. But when you're young
hitting when you're young heading,
it's just like you shouldn't hit until,
you know,
they say probably to high school, but if
you don't hit to you're in high school,
you're going to get left behind.
You know what's interesting about that
is that there's a real good argument when
it comes to striking that if you can
teach kids how to play fight when they're
young, just make sure they
play fight, you know? You know,
you don't want him to like go on a war,
teach and be like that.
The the quick way to teach them,
it teaches them how to play,
fight striking when they're young.
Like do like Thai style kickboxing or you
know like just where you're boxing but
you're not hitting too hard because
they're not going to hit each other art
anyway. Right. They can't, they don't
hit that hard. And then on top of that,
teach them to not hit harder off and
did teach him to like be real solid on
technique.
Then they,
they're super customed to the movements
of striking and then you get them to a
position when they were like 16,
18,
they've been boxing her whole fucking
life and their movements are like fully
ingrained to the point where an average
athlete coming into it at a later age
without all those like super fine tuned,
ingrained in you while you
were growing up and developing.
You almost don't have a chance,
you know,
like when he gets to like a Roy Jones Jr
and his prime level for sure. You know,
if you're like an average
athlete who learns boxing at 26,
and then you, uh, at 30 have
to box Roy Jones, I mean,
good, enjoy that. Good fucking luck. I
don't care what kind of athlete you are.
Good. Doesn't matter. Fucking lock. Yeah.
And some people will make that argument
with, you know, Floyd Mayweather,
they said, listen, his uncle, his dad
he's been doing since he was, what, six.
He's the best argument, the best
argument, the best argument,
who he never gets hit.
It's been hit in a professional
career that spanned 49 fights.
He's been hitting maybe hard seven
or eight times true. The only,
and there's a few x factors in the,
in this fight.
The only kind of thing that gives people
hope if you're on team MMA or team
Connor, which is not MMA for
suboxone, but if your team,
Connor is these x factors of
Floyd's had two years off, right?
He said two years off, but in the past
he's taken time off and comes back better,
but he is 40 and so forth. That has to be
something, you know. And the other thing,
why is he doing it? He's, he do it for
money. What's is do it for attention?
Why is he coming back to get to 50? And
then, uh, they di eight ounce gloves,
which they officially approved today.
Eight ounce gloves is a huge,
huge advance for Connor. And I think,
man, it's all, it's all interesting.
Men call x factors, right? Like we
don't really choose to be honest.
No one really knows. I think I have an
idea what I think's going to happen,
but no one knows. But, and
that's why I think the,
the footage of Connor sparring poly is
such a big deal because people, oh shit,
no,
he can actually box.
And I even think Dana on the Fertittas
who were there watching go, uh,
we actually got something here and that's
why it was such a big deal because I
think everyone's like, all right, Connor
MMA, he's good. I've seen him move around.
I'm playing this, this dude as
far as box. And he's saying,
you've got some problems, isn't he the
best all time problems. Who knows what,
what kind of training and Pauli been
doing before that fight? Like how,
what kind of shape was he in? Non Not
in 12 round shape, you know? And Paul,
he just got off the plane. Why did he
do 12 rounds? Why do you do that? Right.
But he had, he been training, he, uh,
he got word from Conner's team
that they're going to use them.
So he started to train some but not like,
it's not like he was getting
ready for a fight fight, you know,
so that's what he said. He goes, man, you
know, for me to go 12 rounds was tough.
Like I wasn't expecting to all 12 rounds
because the first day they used to him,
I think he said he only did six or
eight rounds and then he was like, oh,
we're going to spar tomorrow morning.
I'll get in better shape. Stuff like that.
Get used to the fighting shape and they
didn't use them. Then he flew to, uh,
cover the, uh, Mikey Garcia, uh, uh,
Broner fight and then came back and
he was fresh off the plane and then he
sparked 12 rounds. So he's like,
they just did me dirty man.
That's his whole thing. His, his
feelings are hurt. He's like, why the,
why would they do that? Man, I was
here to help them. What they did that,
that's the kind of help they want it.
They just want to kind of help
that he didn't want to give,
they wanted to kind of help where Connor
beats the fuck out of a world champ.
Correct. And that's what
Connor said though. Like in
college defense when they go,
you're bringing pollyannas.
Yeah, I'm bringing it.
He said it's on showtime during
the media scrum. He goes, yeah,
I'm bringing him in to fuck him up. And
I think Polly thought, oh that, yeah,
he goes, he goes, yeah, I'm going
to bring him in and fucked him up.
Word for word that's on,
that's on a document that's document.
So then he gets it and goes,
oh, we'll spar and be all good.
But remember six months
prior to this Paul, he goes,
I could beat Conor with one
hand tied behind my back.
I was like a baby elephant.
He's stores. That was a guy,
man. Oh he said that. Oops.
But he thought it was just hyping the
fight. You know, he's not doing sparring,
be like boys,
but it just didn't happen.
Like Connor's liberty there
just to prove a point. Well,
he is a very important point to
prove before a giant fight like that.
Like that video alone is probably worth,
who knows how many thousands of hundreds
of thousands of buys. I'm priceless.
Priceless. That's worth so much
money. I mean how many more people,
a lot of people were going
to buy the fight anyway,
but how many more people are going to buy
the fight now that you see common land
in that straight left and then drop in
Paul and Paul, he said is it pushed down?
And you could see that it's not a
push down. I mean it's just not,
if you get pushed down like that,
you probably can cost already. Yeah.
If your balance is off.
I see what that's so bad.
Like he was saying something about him
getting grabbed on the back of the head.
He could watch it,
watch the knockdown Polly Polly saying
that it's dirty and he didn't get that.
I get that. But that they
signed up. It's a fight.
But the other thing is poly
saying, you know, and he goes take,
what do you want from the videos?
But I think Khan and his team and Dana
fucked up putting this out. Cause now,
now Floyd Mayweather,
the team knows this is the salary fights.
Like this is the dirty stuff he does
so they can warn them that dirty their
hands getting inboxing that sturdy.
You can get away with it,
but that's frowned upon. It's going
to happen. It was rabbit punches,
but that the boy is going to do
that. So this, this part right here.
Gimme some volume on that
so you can hear that.
He's hitting them hard man.
Okay.
Yeah.
He hits him with a straight left that's
clean and then it looks like he's
wobbled and he hit some of
the right hand afterwards.
Like play that part one more time
when it goes down like you can't,
I don't see an argument. I've tried
to look at it a little push down.
I don't see it. I don't see
it. This is the beginning part
then. That's a legit ref by the way.
Yeah. Yeah. Joe Cortez, super legit.
Oh
did,
he's beating the shit out of them.
Okay. I don't give a fuck
what anybody says. Like,
if he can land those
combinations on Pauline melon,
RG like that at any point in life
that is working. But yeah, man,
he's about,
to me that validates counter.
But at the same time and Polly's defense,
you know,
nine 12 round fight shape,
he's exhausted. I get all that,
but still punched it and never
done that. Yeah, he messed up.
He must've underestimated them.
You know, I had uh, uh, uh,
Andre Berto on my show and he's supposed
to help calm her out and he's like,
I ain't going up there. And he's a, he's
a, he's good friends with kind of him.
Connor did Rehab together. He's like,
no, I'm not going up there, man. He goes,
just because he had a good point.
He goes,
let's say I go up there and help Connor.
And for whatever reason he doesn't think
he's going to win because let's say he
blasts away me within the face. I'm gonna
get so much hate from the boxing world.
Like it's a fraternity man. And he's like,
in the way he did Pauli like, we just,
we can't do it, man. He goes, I wish them
the best, but I'm not going to help them.
Well,
also think that if he's peaking and he's
in full fight shape and then making you
fight 12 rounds,
I mean that's when you're in the gym
and you're sparring 12 rounds done.
Isn't that unusual that you get one guy to
barks 12 rounds with you? Oh, no, no, no,
no. It was designed for Paul. You get
beat up, but then I feel like, uh,
you know Paul, he's a team player. If,
I don't know if you've ever met Paul,
he loves you, but if you
ever met Paul, he like,
I feel like he's such a good
guidance. Say anything. Listen,
if you brought me in to do anything I
have had guys off for wanting me to help
him with camps, I turn it
down and you're like, hey,
we need to go five five that ain't
happening. I'll give you one round,
two rounds for your,
for the best condition.
Usually do a shark tank is Joe bringing
fresh guys for different looks and push
you harder. So this is just a showcase of
Connor's abilities at Paulie's expense.
Yup. I like Paul. He's a commentator. I
think he's one of his best in the world.
He's really, really good. And
he offers like real, legitimate
insight. He's vitally,
really good to think that he
got rocked and doesn't deserve,
remember how this went?
Like did he think that he meet bring,
maybe did think that he got
pushed down? No, I it again,
I think it's combination
of both. I think, you know,
Polly had one summer and he even says,
he goes,
I want some rounds Koller one somewhere.
You know, I like to see it all right.
Me Too. And the UFC said they're gonna
release it after the fight, which is that,
that's going to be the real test
is going to be real tested. What?
Cause Dana said it was a
one sided beat down. Yeah.
It was like he was asked what for 12
rounds, which I don't believe that.
What if it's true? Uh, you, you,
you gotta go with what Polly did say
happened and then what you see happened.
I think it's combination of both.
I really do. I think, again,
I think it's people were like, Yo, you
know, everyone's on this Connor wagon,
especially in the UFC. Dana,
that's his golden boy. Right?
And I think we knew Conor could box,
but then when you see him do it
against Paul, you're like, oh shit.
And so even I bet when we watch
the tape where I'm like, oh damn,
Connor did pretty well. I don't think he
beat the shit out Pauline for 12 rents.
I think towards the end he probably
like, you see that that gap, that hole,
obviously, listen, this has
obviously been very valuable.
If there were more moments like this,
don't you think they would leak those two?
Correct.
There'd be everywhere.
I mean they're saying they don't want him
to see what Connor's working on. Okay.
Just show us a mock punches that landed.
Just give me like what it was Mike Tyson
Siki second highlights to show me a few
bap bap, bap. Bap. Bap.
Bap. Bap. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean you don't have to like
show all of its patterns,
but how well did this hype that like
this is priceless giant. And now Paulie,
you know you have this huge soap
opera in box and going right now.
Polly's a main character now.
So Paul,
he might have to fight Conor if Floyd
and Floyd and even had Floyd and Connor,
if Floyd beats Conor and
then Paul, he can say, look,
I want my shot at him.
You know you,
you talked a lot of shit and I didn't
get in shape. If you're not relaxed,
the play, it's only, it's only the play.
If Connor has a good showing,
even if you live in the decision,
as long as it gets showing right,
then you do McGregor promotions against
Polly Mellen Naji and I'll buying that
shit. The only way. Fighting
Khabib, Tony Ferguson,
all that elbow just Jitsu Shit.
Nah,
we are putting on these eight ounces,
go 12 rounds
and make some,
I need some serious money.
That's a lot of people think
on their fight MMA again.
I mean he's gonna make $100 million
from this fight. Yeah, probably more.
That's the sponsors. Yeah, that's
a lot of money. That's scrooge.
Mcduck rich. That's,
that's we go and sizzler.
[inaudible]. It has a son, you know,
he's a smart guy. I think the play would,
and I know a lot of, you'll see people
like that because he never fight or shop.
I get that.
Give any UFC fighter $100 million.
They're both thrown up to
C's going spach and see ya.
This is way too hard of a life.
Hundred Mil.
He's even satin sheets and I can go fight
Polly for another whatever, 50 mill,
probably of my own money or,
or I'll go fight Nate Diaz
and the trilogy, 90% or more.
Connor Mcgregor versus Floyd Mayweather
money man says notorious will lose 90%
of his $75 million payday
if he's disqualified. Yeah,
yeah, I know that. Yeah.
Oh yeah. That's, that's,
if he doesn't know my may move on him
and he won't be us up all the time.
Can you tell a superman punch spinning
punch? I'm like, get out of my face.
The absolutely not.
You can't,
it's just caddy can throw
spinning back fist though. Whoa.
Magic that ship some Gut, some gentlemen
rules for guts. You imagine now if,
if Floyd said, uh, you could throw elbows,
I'm surprised he has an eight ounce
gloves, will do whatever you want to do.
Let's do this. Let's do this. You imagine
and you get elbows and he gets thrown.
One kick around and the guy can clinch
and throw elbows from the clench.
Do you ever see that?
The sequence where Jordan me and
knocked out Cyborg and strike force.
Oh my oldest nasty.
He's one of the nastiest,
nastiest sequences of standing elbows.
Holes like,
like a fucking seminar on
how to land a standing elbow.
The most vicious elbow hall time.
Cyborg is taking some shots to the dome.
Dude, he got from my Cavedin page,
the knee k page, kill and die.
He did God damn near killed him. I
mean yet to have all constructive. Oh,
he didn't like, he basically had to
put like mesh wiring all over his face.
Now he's a superhero and he said he was
going to fight again and then he change
his mind. Yeah. Let's not
do that though. Huh? I mean,
who knows how his dome works right now.
I mean,
after you get hit like that and you're
set goal pours in poor to very poor.
Who knows? Everyone's different.
It won't change the different,
here it is right here. Look at this. He
hits him with a liver shot, a left right?
Doesn't happen till they get to
the kitchen here. Boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom. I mean,
look at that. I mean, come on man.
Who's the rays? Hit Him with like 13
fucking straight elbows to the head.
Did you think they stopped the CIF?
Joan's early? I mean late. Yes.
Yes. Right? Yes. Yeah. I
think you're, you know,
like you're giving the guy the best
chance he can. Your John McCarthy,
you know how tough he is.
John's the best in the world too.
So they're size two punches
too late. Yeah. Well,
and you kind of three also like the
delayed effect,
that head kick.
I get head kicked and you see his like
legs buckle and he's wobbling around and
then when he goes down
up against the cage,
I mean it wasn't like a real
significant thing that ha,
he's like his legs weren't
working right? No. It's game over.
Like the game's over there was already
hurt bad and then John Jumps on top of
them. It's just wailing on him. You,
he could've stopped at one or two punches
earlier, but you know in his eyes,
what if DC recovers? What if
he rolls over? Gets to guard.
What if he holds on to John?
I believe his lived to fight another day.
I agree with you too.
I totally agree with you,
but I'm just looking at it
from John's point. I did it.
I don't like criticizing giants. She's
like, man, I thought that was too late.
A lot of people thought that was too.
Yeah,
it's tough to watch with DCM and my
thing with DC and you talked about and
coming back, he's, you
know, he's, what is he,
39 38 39 he has a great job with
the UFC as far as UFC tonight.
Right. He's kind of becoming
that. The guy you'll see tonight,
he's doing commentating. We do.
He's traveling all around now.
He's great at commentary. You know?
Does he ever be John? I don't think so.
So what are you going to do? Fight
Gustin again, those, the know,
I don't know what his pay is, but
you know, at some point, you know,
health has to take into account with this.
Yeah.
The Gustafson fight was a grueling
five round fight. You know,
I remember there was a very,
very, very good for us.
It's been test fucking close man. It's
better now than ever before. He too.
That's why I want to see him and
John Ken's glow over. I was like,
Jesus Christ looked amazing and the
combinations he was landing that hazing,
that whipped like upper
cut from the outside.
See the thing about him is he's the only
guy that can match John for distance
and reach size. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, no
one else is like him, not even close.
And Gustafson is also more
mobile than John. Like he's,
John is like very creative,
mixes things up more.
But Gustafson is more like bouncing
around better footwork and his better
footwork for sure.
Yeah.
He's very agile and he's also the first
guy to ever Atlanta take town on John.
Yes. And I think he's better. I think
he's better now that he wants then we too.
That'd be, that'd be a great fight.
Fuck yeah, that would be, you know,
they were asking John how about John
was on Good Morning America getting
interviewed by Michael Strahan. Good
Lord to things change. Wow. Yeah. Right.
So he's on Good Morning America
and the ask them about what's next.
And he talked about, you know,
he'd like to fight Brock.
Like that's always been kind of his thing.
And Connor kind of set that with
the super fights. But you know,
Brock can't fight too. I think whatever
it has, 18 months or some shit,
I'm sure it was slipping in the back door.
So I'm shit like what's,
what's this juice to the
gills? I'd still watch it. Um,
so they talked to about Gus fin. They
go, what about mass square garden?
And he was not happening
cause they weren't taxed me
another 10% of fight in New
York. So He's like, I won't
find maths work on. Wow. I know.
I feel like you'll see like fuck your
10% here, just finding a squirt gun.
Let's figure this out. Take a little
extra pieces of the mighty mass.
Give us something to perhaps they
might even say no, give me that.
Would if John Put uh, uh, uh, no
steroid test clause, I Guy Brock,
oh, take your shit. Fuck you do your
shit. I'm gonna do my copay and you know,
we missed and I'd be up all night long.
No
drug test. Cause that's all talking
about doing like Dubai or some shit.
But if he just says, tell him, look,
I don't give a fuck what you do,
I'm going to beat your ass. And
then Brock's gotta go, Oh my God.
It's like full bane.
Sheth
drug gets up to two 90 cuts down at two
65 I don't know if John could fuck with
that. I don't, that's a scary
dude. Mccain fucked up backup,
you know King County.
But he did have the stomach issue.
Diverticulitis, right ovary muscle
fucked him up when he was being broked.
Well that was a crazy fight for him to
take after recovering from surgery where
he got 12 inches of his colon removed
and we talk in Uber Ring. Yeah,
that was ubering to the man's got like
a straight up murder when he was two 65
kicked in the gut. He just
had surgery there. Hit that.
Obering see that.
It's like,
he's like one of the best
arguments for no testing.
He's still kind of killing it
with the old too. He's great,
but it's a different Overeem
like this Overeem the Ha,
the heavyweight grom pre k one
heavyweight Grand Prix Overeem.
There's never been a fight like
that before. Like look at this size.
They're never going to see
that again ever. In the UFC.
Physiques he was so jacked.
They look like giant Phil Heath.
Like you're never going to see these
two again and kicked like that and he's
just all over him.
Brought to the gut down.
He's got some of the best knees in
the businessmen. Super good technique,
which just I, I missed this
Overeem where he was just dying.
People with power. You'll
never see the, the,
the Overeem now that can be dumb.
Fucking has been kicked to the gut. The
Overeem now that uh, his steroid free.
Like he, he, he does that move where
he runs a lei steroid over him.
Never ran
saying like on steroids. [inaudible]
good luck in miss step an inch bat.
Now he's clean. That fuckers sprinting,
remedy fought Todd Duffy and dream.
Do you ever see that fight?
I trained Tom for that fight
and I suppose to corner him.
Todd Duffy was super
promising before that fight.
We'll talk took on short notice. I
don't do it. I wouldn't be broke.
Got To fight who over him dream dough.
I don't do that. Listen, you have
a lot of talent. You could be huge.
This is not the way to get huge.
She gets a bad idea.
Alliterated in Japan
with short notice Japan.
What is it about calling people
like a week before the fight going?
What are you up to Saturday?
All advantages for it,
for the home team then,
and wasn't this post UFC Duffy because
he had that UFC fight where he won like
it was one of the fastest fights ever.
One out with a jab in seconds,
breath and peace to him. Hey. Yeah,
rest in peace to anguish. Terrible,
terrible story. Duffy's Gigi Jack
too. He was super jacked. So talented.
I'll really, really talented stupid.
He goes in there and he fights.
Overeem ad is most Overeem ever.
They'll look at it and I'm confident is,
yeah,
it's like a death sentence.
He was a monster back then.
And then when you think about him,
like bordering on both sports,
right?
He's like k one grand Prix
champions still fighting MMA.
It's all again the same time period.
And his striking is just off the charts
because of it and you can't take him
down. Yeah. So Duffy just went after
him [inaudible] and everything.
Boom. He gets cuts the mood for Duffy
though. Yeah, it is a move. He gets old.
The body shot body gets Duffy
here that you write here about.
I'm not backing up to look. It just
boomed so much power forward. Right hand.
Left hand running from
[inaudible]. He wasn't running. No.
Did his thought process. Now
I'm a fucking yeah. Slides out.
Delay. Well, he's also older and
he's taken more punishment to you.
Gotta think though.
Knockouts that he's had just in the UFC.
Steve Bay knocked him unconscious.
Um,
Travis Browne knocked him
unconscious a while ago. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean there's been how many,
how many people knocked him out?
He has his more knocked out losses.
Anyone in the EOC? Yeah. Um,
brothel knocked him out. Rothwell
Steve Bay. He beat JDF didn't. Yes,
he did. He knocked him out. He
didn't lens a couple of issues. Yeah,
but I'm trying to think of
other fights that he's had.
I'll tell you what I'd love to see
Overeem versa. Your boyfriends, you know.
Oh my God. I would love to send it to
says jds coming up, but oh, that's right.
Big Foot Silva knocked him out too.
Oh that big foot civil one was rough.
That was a rough one.
It was real rough cause he was standing
up and big foot Tito on. I'm just Ding,
Ding, Ding, Ding, Ding,
Ding. But then look at him.
He merged dude's share of Nelson JDS or
Lawsky loses Steve Bay for the title.
This true fight was brutal. No,
that Mark Hunt fight was rough.
The flat road market market's fine again.
It's right in that Russian dues, right?
Like 10 or something. Yeah. Yeah.
He's fighting a isn't that a,
is that in Australia? Yeah.
Australia and New Zealand one
[inaudible] still good move man.
You have a fucking Mark Hunt fight New
Zealand. He's a huge draw. Oh my God.
Gigantic Sydney to Boris fighter
man. Soon to Boris. Like guts.
Sneaky, sneaky left high kick Judy's
Russians. And though that that whole area,
they might fuck you there had taken over
box and they're slowly creeping in. MMA.
How about it could be,
I know what's going on with him.
Well he got Tony First and Kevin
Lino fight for the interim title.
They just don't think can be, can make
the weight. I don't know what's going on.
They asked him to fight, right? And
he was like, no, I need more time.
It's just the boats passing them by
more time. What's, it must be injured.
Look Tiramisu. I Dunno. Terribly.
And I like could be such a talent,
but like, it's so frustrating.
I fucking love Tiramisu. Oh, I get it.
Could be no, it's like when you don't,
you know, you shouldn't be
eating this, but you're like,
fuck it. Let's get dessert.
If I go, what? Do you have
dessert. And they go, well,
we have world famous Tiramisu.
Bring that. Oh, then you got some coffee
with it. A double espresso, please.
I gotcha. I get it. I get it. They
don't have the, here's the thing,
my man campaigns, uh, runs these
ultra marathons every year.
Last year he ran the big foot, 2000
or 200. It's two oh five, 205 miles.
And this year he's running
this Moab one 234 miles.
He cuts down from 180 pounds,
which is what he weighs normally.
He's down to one 60 now.
Jesus, he know how he does it.
He works out and burns off more
calories than eats. That's it. But then,
and he feels good doing it. Yeah.
He'll bike burn off 3000 calories.
Eat 2000 I mean if he look
different though, if he can do it,
if he can do that then Khabib can
do that too. They can all do that.
All you have to do is just work hard,
do a lot of fucking cardio,
put a lot of hours in training
and eat less than you're eating.
Here's the thing though. You'll shrink,
you'll shrink. Yeah. That's it's science.
But here's the thing,
you can hire someone to do that to
make sure you make that weight. Well,
he's also look a very strict Muslim
and so he, he celebrates Ramadan.
Yeah. Which makes it a real
issue for guys to fight.
Although someone just did that in the UFC,
um, Ramadan. Yeah. And got through it
but through Ramadan.
But his nickname is,
remember the name Billao Mohamad Mohamad
went through Ramadan while he was
training.
He just did it very smart.
And he scheduled is training for
after his meal. A lot of Batta. Yeah.
And he fought great with Khabib though.
It's like, you know, at 55 kind of,
but cluster fuck there and he's
just getting left in the dust.
I think it's his Bot I think is real
issues with his body from losing those
amounts of weight. Let's boil it and
listen, I love Ak and they've done, uh,
you know, I think, um, you know crazy.
Bob Cook should belongs in the
UFC hall of Fame Hall of fame.
He's a straight up genius. Him
and Javier. Yeah, but those boys,
I don't know what's going on there with
Kane. You know, you've got the, you know,
well, you know what it is for
awhile. Here's what I think it is.
You got at the top level of that.
You have to have the best,
first of all, arguably the best
heavy weight ever and cane.
And then he got one of the best light
heavyweights ever and Daniel and they're
going to war all the time.
But Thompson and, but, and
Luke Rockhold in the mix too.
And they also, you only have a certain
amount of years of being able to do that.
So then he,
she Keynes body breaking down.
I mean you can't just attribute that only
to his training there because there's
some questionable weightlifting videos
of him online. The dead lift. Yeah.
Well it's,
it's not even a dead man.
It's like he's doing a kettle bell swing
with like shit form and they're doing
high reps of all kinds of weird shit.
I got saw a lot like Steve
Maxwell saw and he was furious.
But the thing is a lot of them and
make guys, if they don't come from a,
like a football background in most of
them you don't see lift like that to be
honest.
Well,
it's problem was he had a trainer and
the people were feeling like the trainer
was doing a shit job.
But yeah, I mean, yeah,
100% I mean as far as naming injuries
and delays in fights on eight k but I
think, and it's not up to them. I
think you, again, like you were saying,
you have the toughest guys in the world
competing every day. You have Khabib,
you have all these guys and
things are going to happen.
I think there's two different schools of
thought, and I don't know who's right.
There's a school of thought where you
just fucking go in there and you'd go to
war all the time and the cream rises
to the top and you get hardened by the
combat and you come out of it, the best
fighter in the 1997, you know what,
it was cane for a while, right? Until
all these injuries started piling up.
But I think there's another
way of looking at it. Well,
there's two different other ways
of looking at it. There's the,
and when you get to a Connor situation,
then you get a super camp.
It's designed around you,
and then you get these people who are
working with you on various aspects of
your game. You're sparring
partners or plan accordingly.
There's a bunch of people
that you work with that,
you know are their goal is to
get you better for this fight.
And I would say GSPs one
who really started that for
sure. For us. A hobby. Yeah.
Yeah. And, um, I think these
guys that are doing this today,
you know, it's like how do you do
it? Do you do it the old school way,
which has always been proven. You can
make some tough motherfuckers that way.
Or do you do at the att way when you
have this gigantic program where you have
all world class coaches and athletes
and you're putting together all these
people and you know,
I mean you just have a giant super team
look at their roster too. But again,
but you know, not that Javier didn't
have a competition background,
but the reason why t so good and they're,
they're killing it with a Yolana Jen,
Jen, check with fucking Amanda Nunez. All
their big athletes. Mike Brown, right?
He's been there. He's done it. He's
awesome. Yeah. Yeah. To me, you know,
he definitely top three in the boreal,
the boreal too. But Mike Brown really,
he's only,
he's focused on Yolana and Amanda Nunez
and he's focusing because he's been
there, he's done those
meathead days. Things going,
we need to focus more on this.
So when you have someone,
even team Alpha Male,
I don't have a ton of injuries really.
Granted Cody Garbrandt seven his things,
but Uriah faber,
he's been through it.
So you need these younger guys who have
been through it who are going to take
control, who are saying, listen,
we can't be Vander Lee Silverman.
This isn't meant the top team,
this ain't working in football.
Same Way like Jim Hart at
Michigan, they don't hit, he goes,
if you don't have to hit at this level,
you're not going to make it. Right.
They only hit on game days when it counts.
Right.
So you see this kind of trend happening
with people who've been through it
before, like a cowboy cowboy
hardly respires anymore.
Yeah, he does mostly drills.
Mitt work, you know it your own too. Like
you see this kind of guy that's like,
man, I can't begin beat up in training
anymore more. It doesn't make sense.
God Damn. Especially at
heavyweight, you know,
big guys the size of Mitch around giving
each other brain damage, bad idea,
terrible that I can only
do it so many times.
And I think when you see a guy like Conor
with all the different experimenting
that he does with like weird movements,
Tufts with that ido portal
guy like rights and shit.
Even the weird shit that he does,
like when you see him like
switching stances in the,
in the rings switching stances,
like a taekwondo guy,
like he's in a taekwondo tournament.
If he all that weird shit,
if he can do shit like that,
the Floyd,
all that stuff that he's never seen
before. Sideways stance, you know,
moving more like a karate fighter.
He's going to come out more karate than
people are expecting us. I as poly,
you know, I said, you know Polly has
his issues with and I'm like, yeah,
that's terrible. But
how was, how was this,
was it as awkward as I'm predicting
cause yeah, no, Carter goes,
it goes in and get starch. My time,
I'm out showtime. That's my time.
Have a good night. You know what I'm
saying? Like I look like an asshole.
But he was saying, he was like, Nah man,
he gets even more awkward than
I than I thought. Like, it's,
it's tough to deal with. He said one time
it has palm up like this. Yeah. Like,
like Leo Machida Shit. Oh, it's definitely
going to do that. And it plays like,
I have no idea who that is.
I'm like look him up.
He doesn't know who the auto Machida's.
How dare, how daring Polly, how dare you.
He knows Jujitsu. That was like
my morse prediction of all time.
Welcome to the MACHITA era.
Probably my worst predictions. Oh,
there was a Machida
era. No, not like that.
Like he lost right away after
that we murked show guns. Right.
Murked Rashad. Well he didn't Merch
Shogun shogun knocked him out.
Oh that's right. Get lost him. But
they had that back and forth. Right.
Well he ended up or shot. He fucked
up or shot knowing the title 10 title.
Who beat him right after that
and then John crushed him.
And then once John crush
him crush his dreams. Yeah.
And then it drops down to 85 great.
Against Munoz.
There was a Leo Machida like when we say
the air, I mean yeah, there was still,
but I try to use the game.
He definitely changed a lot,
but I thought he was going
to go on a crazy run man.
So as we got there John Jones to to to do,
uh oh he lets her rampage but that
had to go back a little bit more.
Go back a little bit more. So where
does, where does the Rashad fight? Okay,
so he fought Rashad and then he fought.
That's what it is. He fought shogun next,
but he should have lost
that fight and he won,
but still yet a lot and then
show you lots of two years.
So remember he beat dealer that and that's
real Tito Ortiz. Merck Thiago Silva.
At the time Thiago Silva was f
straight savage destroys Rashad.
Then he ekes by Shogun.
What he meant when he jumped in front,
kicked Randy in the face and knocked out.
Randy's too.
That was good. Yeah. That
was a little rough from them.
Then he fought John beat Ryan Bader
with that crazy knockout. That was nuts.
Ryan being a ran into that crazy,
a straight left hand just rushed him.
Those here in a la and the Munoz fight.
I remember that was in like London.
Some shit. I remember Munios
Fan. I was trained with Munoz.
He found out through social media
is fighting Machida. It was like,
Oh fuck that was in England. Whoa.
Then he got smashed by Weidmann.
Hey did they CB dollar and then
Rockhold one was the worst.
That was marijuana is really bad too.
That was gruff and then he tested
positive for something, right? Yeah.
And then I don't know exactly
what he's doing now. Yeah man.
You get a certain amount of knockouts
against guys like Rockhold and especially
the Rockhold one was rough to
get on top of doing it though.
He's been doing karate since
he was fucking three months
old and he's just been
doing it for a long ass time and yeah,
it's interesting like these guys
like Vito and him where their, their,
their technique is still there.
Their mind is still there but their
body just can't keep up. Again,
we'll give it a shot,
give a shot.
That's to me that when I looked
at his fight in Mexico City,
he's fighting on the undercard against
Sam, Alvin Miguel. Oh my God, man.
And I love Rashad and the guy had been
trading with forever and to see him,
and I don't think,
I don't know if the matter of physical,
but mentally you can tell he's just not,
he's not there as far as,
not that he's punchy,
but he just doesn't want to do anymore.
Like he's not pulling the trigger.
He's been knocked out before.
I was the same way. Once I got knocked
out, fee things change. Go. Okay,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not going to fight like that anymore.
That kind of caution in the wind. Let's
go. Let's sit in the pocket and bang. No,
no, no, no, no. I've learned from that.
And then Rashad just couldn't
pull the trigger. I, I think,
I think he's swaying towards being done
well. He's holds a shrine now. Shit.
How old is Rashad? Him? He gets 39 yeah,
he's up there. Yeah, he's had a great run.
He's definitely had a great run,
but you obviously enjoys doing it or he
wouldn't be still doing it or the money.
Yeah. I don't know. One of the 37 yeah,
but the other thing with our shot is
the games advanced so much further than
wrestler with good boxing. You can't,
you can't fuck with that anymore.
At light heavyweight middleweight
welterweight, you go down. What?
You only have to ask, you only
have two tools. You're screwed man.
I kinda like yard Rodriguez. All these
young kids go, you only Rasul and box.
Oh my God, I'm eating him
alive. But he can kick. I mean,
remember he knocked out Sean Salmon with
that high care got 10 as old school and
Sean Sam and looked like every
ups driver we've ever had. Yeah.
But I would would think that he
would get better at that. You know,
and it just never became
like a big part of his game.
His game was never like
full on Moyie Thai oriented.
Now it's like the Chuck Ladell thing.
You know where sprawl and brawl.
I'm going to fuck you up with my hand.
Crazy as he trains with Tyrone Spong.
I know.
I mean,
Tyrone Spong is fucking demon
when it comes to standup man.
Dude, he Merck's, this dude's so bad.
And this was at light heavyweight,
which is interesting because all along
a lot of people thought he should be at
one 85 he won the ultimate
fighter heavyweight come crazy.
Is that if I Brad imes. Yes.
Giant ass dude in the finals.
Yeah, Rochelle. It's just tough man.
And he's a dude to play football too,
right? Yeah, high school. But
then he wrestled at Michigan
State. His roommate was,
uh, Greg, uh, Maynard crazy man.
And then the other roommate is a big
agent at CAA, which is hilarious.
All them are killing it.
You know, you remember, uh,
his knock out of chocolate dough. That
was probably like the biggest highlight.
Our Oh,
AV or in the UFC really wouldn't play it.
Just Chuck Ladell was like the main man.
Remember for a while there they went
play the chuck or Rhonda knockouts turn
that bitch on, fosters the loop.
Well, once WMA became the owners,
they're like lists and like we don't
play that game where we're here to self.
Correct. I know he's your boy. Oh,
there it is. Right there.
One shot, I was a crazy,
crazy high kick. They sh, I think they
showed the chocolate. They'll knock out.
They just didn't highlight it
over and over. Over a long time.
They went show chuck or Rhonda
that Chuck one was so like,
I remember that sound of that right
hand land. Just Blab, upper cut.
Oh No.
Chuck was going to throw the upper cut,
his famous upper gut and then just that
and reshot depth Dover with the overhand
right on the fucking button,
like a gunshot.
I remember chage turmeric path, like
his heart. He's like, yeah, here it is.
Chuck's just, chuck was just such
a fucking executioner. Chuck.
There's rumors chuck wanted to fight
again. He's in Thailand Training Shit.
Wow.
Hello.
Great timing by Rashad.
Perfect.
Bowshot look at the fucking impact
to that right hand that it's crazy.
My God. You know, talking about
chuck and Tito again and Bella tour,
we'll talk about shale and Tito. They're
talking about challenge Tito first,
the child, Taylor talking shit
to each other. They just fight.
They just fight and catch
a neck reconstructed and
he has a tube in his neck.
But then chill, start talking
shit to fake discs. Oh my God.
He got discs replaced it. We'd go
full. Go to Tito's a Instagram page.
He talked about it and then he
said, chill, I'm kicking your ass.
It was like so progress. Hey Tito, chill.
I love both of you. Now I may know,
but he tried to watch that shit. A
ballot. Ours Pan. No one's watching it.
I just saw it still sell.
He does still a draw in the,
you know,
if he could talk chill and it talking
some shit about him and people want to see
them happening. Get Pete up again.
It's actually a video though.
If you play the video, Jamie, it's on
his uh, somewhere on his Instagram.
Oh look at that to say
winter. His neck, um,
go to is just the whole thing and I'll
show you where it is. If you find it.
There it is. That's it. Listen,
let's play some volume on this.
Alright. Surgery's done. Three
them off desk replacement.
And so you want to fight,
Huh?
Disc replacement on my server,
which is the neck area either let me call
[inaudible] Smith and amazing
job. Valerie. Thank you so much.
Thank you
that your sport, everybody reached out
to me and Bridget sport. I'm alive.
I'm fixed now. It's time
to get ready cause chill.
I'm kicking your ass.
Wait a minute.
But how crazy is that?
A guy coming out of knee
neck reconstruction.
He got three discs replaced.
Like do you know when the UFC,
if you have more than
two discs replaced Ila,
they don't think they are letting your
fight right now. Uh, it makes sense.
They were talking about um,
uh, Rick story. Rick story
has some disc replacements.
It was neck. Yeah. And they're like,
if you get to a certain amount,
like we've got one your lower
back one your neck like Ooh son,
we're not sure if we want
to fuck with this liability.
Well who knows how good the guy
did the neck thing. Like who,
who did your thing like it's almost
like, oh, like who's building your car?
We'll send them to your guy. Then UFC
like 70, the one guy who we can trust.
Yeah.
How he shut down this career.
How many dudes are doing this
neck reconstruction thing?
Everyone switched over looking for a deal
at Eddie Bravo has got his back done.
You know Eddie still having problems
with it though. It's not 100%.
A lot of people have problems with it.
I mean the backs tricky man. But uh,
one of the, one of his students, victor
had his done and he's a big dude.
He's real big. He was like heavyweight
dude and it for him it's fine.
Like he was lifting weights like really
quickly and got back to Roland within a
few months. I think it just depends man.
But with Tito, he's had so much of the,
you know,
abuse as far as wrestling and fighting.
He's got fusions too.
He's got all sorts of shit going on.
Kakoa straight up fighter it. Neck
brace, Tongan chill. Get your ass ready.
Like we're looking at, we're looking
at like a year from now, bro.
Like how long does it take to recover from
those surgeries? I wonder because, uh,
what Eddie was saying was that,
you know,
like he might have pushed it too quick
and like reinjured it a little bit.
I rarely went,
came and hit.
Did he come in here like the next day
we're doing [inaudible] pain and he was
like drinking high off his ass and
we're talking about, and he's like,
I'm not gonna rush into it.
Like I'm not doing much.
But then if you're on the mats and you
know, this problem is rolling is too fun.
Yeah, you can't roll if
you're injured. You know,
I think the only thing you should do ever,
if you're injured his drill and just use
it as a time to drill because you can
get really good, he'd get really good by
drilling, but as soon as you're, like,
if you're dealing with something
that's recovering like a surgery,
if you like, have to explode and
exert weird energy and weird ways,
you never know, like you,
you don't want to get tapped.
You don't want your guard to get past you
don't want, so you'll just fucking la.
You're in the middle of it, you'll
law. And when you do that, ma'am,
palm messes it up. You feel the back
where you got surgery twinge again.
You're like, ah, came over
fucked all that worked up.
I'll tell you what's crazy speaking of
injuries is when I saw patty hooligan and
Dublin, he and he's the
outgoing cro, you know,
smart dudes speaks well we're
talking. I'm like, Dude.
So once the next fight and his whole
team was just like, God dammit. I'm like,
what?
I didn't hear him.
But he has a rare blood disorder,
like less than 1% of the world have it.
And it's really not that dangerous.
But if it did, if something were to
happen, it's like super dangerous.
So the UFC is like, it's too much of a
risk. We can't, can't clear you to fight.
So he's done. Whoa. So how
does the blood disorder work?
I'm not sure you got me. I'll
have to look it up. Jamie.
He has some super rare blood disorder.
Super,
super rare where you'll
have to look it up for,
I don't want to this concern like if he
needs a transfusion or something. Yeah,
something like that where the UFC, he's
just too high of a risk. So he's done.
But he was open a gym without SBG with
Connor at their gym and then he decided
to do his own like up the street. Why
you're doing that. But crazy story man.
Crazy. I had no idea. I felt
I felt bad for him. But good
spirits, man. Good spirits.
He's going to start doing podcasts and
I want to start doing some other stuff.
Well that's cool. You
know, here it is. Um,
he was born with a factor missing
in his blood called factor 13.
I never disclosed it until now and came
to the UFC is attention from a third
party. I can no longer pass the
medical requirements to compete.
Only one in 5 million people are
diagnosed. So I knew that it was rare.
Organizations wouldn't understand or
take a chance at me as a found out.
Now I never explained in full to
John on my team the actual risks.
Cause I didn't think there
was accessible access risks.
What it sort of, if it's not, if he
doesn't think there is an access risk,
it's a disorder that is only
dangerous for me and not my opponents.
I really did see MMA is a way to have
a real shot at life for myself and my
family and it turns out I was right. Wow.
I have mixed emotions. This is a sad,
can you look up the disorder?
How sad is it when you talk about a guy
who his spirits are super up like he was
joking about it. He's just like,
what the fuck you know? He is a,
he's a son and his girl was there and
I was like, oh I felt so bad for him,
but he was like, doll ball. I got
this. I'm doing my thing here at SPG.
I got my own gym.
You know like things are good and
I'm starting getting the podcast.
He's going to be good at it too, man.
If you can get that good at fighting,
you get that good at anything.
You just have to think about it the right
way here. It is. It is. It's a rare oh,
clotting. Oh yeah. Ooh.
A bleeding disorder characterized by a
deficiency of clotting factor 13 clotting
factors or specialized proteins that
are essential for the blood to clot
properly. Oh, he's like a
hemophilia, uncontrolled
bleeding episode. Fuck all that.
Like what if you get a Marvin Eastman
and the head starts in foreign blood and
they can't stop it.
You know,
like something about foreheads
like forehead just bleed a lot.
So should with them now. Elbows as you
show. Yes. Peak of the elbow. Hit like,
think about how much more forehead's
bleeding like a knee. Oh yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Elbows like fucking if we get needed,
it's always in the face.
You're shit's all fucked up with patty.
It's a bummer man. One in 5 million.
Crazy. And what are the odds? I know, man.
Super heartbreaking. Do you know the odds
on Floyd Mayweather and Conor McGregor?
Only four to one. Five to
one, right. Connor, I saw it.
Maybe it's changed the
article's odd swing.
I'd been on this hound,
this Connor decried hound changing
complete Conner date. Just changing the
odds. You really think he's got a chance.
Yeah, I do. He's Beverly. Dude is a lot
bigger, man. It's like a Mack truck.
He's awkward Floyd. Two
years off. I'm, I'm,
I'm a little curious why it was still
a junior. Bernard Hopkins. Correct.
Plus Three 25 whoa.
Whoa. It's down to three.
Take it back. Jesus Christ.
Praise Zit in my four fifth do you
wanna hear something hilarious?
Those odds are things,
those are odds are smaller than
when he fought Canelo that's crazy.
Those odds are changing because of the,
the fucking video.
Just a matter of amount of
people were betting on Conner.
I know how people are listening.
They might not know
what the odds are. I would, I explain
odds. People are like, what the fuck man,
how you win 100 bucks.
Most people,
I have to explain it every time we
go to the UFC to send someone. Yeah.
When the odds first came out,
I fucked up.
I thought you got 26 one I got
at 15 to 100 win by knockout.
It's always so weird when you see the
numbers like plus four 50 like how who
comes out in the open with it,
you know if they opened with an odd,
that's when it gets really crazy.
How do they do that?
And it's like an expert opinion.
They do it on purpose to get you they
cause they want bedding so they show our
purpose to get people to go here.
Show Floyd loves us.
Cause you know Floyd always bets
on himself in a Shitload of money.
So Floyd's like yes,
keep it going.
Did you see a footage came out that is
not footage but news leaked and I think
it's all honey dicking that Zap Judah
knocked that Floyd Mayweather and training
and Floyd shut down the gym. What?
Yeah, look that shit up Jamie.
Pull that shit up.
Jamie telling you this APP Judah
yesterday they said knock them out.
I think it's all smoke and mirrors.
I think Floyd just trying
to sell this to the Max.
Well that would be smart. I'm Floyd's
part is brilliant. How close is he?
Would Zap Judah that they would organize
that? I mean SAP Jews like, yeah,
I'll take that. Shine was the last time
you mentioned the name Psap. Judah.
Very good point.
Word from inside the money teams Abdu
to knocked out Floyd maybe in sparring
during a wild exchange where
both boxes began to brawl.
Apparently Floyd kicked everyone out
of the gym afterwards. More to come.
Zap was mimicking Connor and
just came right after him. Whoa.
Says Mario Vegas Post Mario
Vegas and we trust Mario. Mario.
Talk to me. Well, look at him.
That glamor shot, glamor shot.
Head shot bothers the fuck out.
It doesn't bother me at all.
He looks like a very reasonable
American's 14 tweets.
I'm sure a hundred followers.
Sure he votes conservative.
You know what I think you could have a
conversation with. I think he's a troll.
I wouldn't mind having a beer with them.
I don't believe that.
I think there'd be more smoked.
I think literally Floyd's just
playing this full. He'll like,
I got knocked out. Look Conner
definitely a week before or word Zap.
Judah and him might have gone to war
because he does go to Warren gyms.
He does make you seem talk shit and
go to war warm with people in sparring
sessions as Abdula Young
Ethan's. Absolutely. It's true.
But Zap Judy can crack. We
know that factors. Yeah.
He cracked Floyd a few times when they
fought, if you remember that he can crack.
Yeah. Floyd Mayweather and Zap
Judah unleash chaos in Las Vegas.
April. Yeah. Wow.
It's back at the temperate battle between
Mayweather and the current sparring
partners have Judah. Yeah. They had
a great war man. Phenomenal fun.
And if Zap Judah, I mean look,
zap Jude is lightning fast.
If he hasn't lost a step and they actually
did get into a wild exchange and he,
Floyd got crazy. It is entirely
possible. It hasn't lost a step.
I mean guarantee has.
Yeah, probably. Probably.
I mean as far as like his speed and power,
I bet it's still there.
I mean it's like timing,
but I'm what I'm trying to set you right.
His reaction to losing a staff is
probably not the best way to describe it,
but he's still got it skills and he's
still got some serious power for shows how
to drop bombs.
And if he drops a bomb on Floyd,
if they really did have
some crazy exchange,
it's 100% possible that you could imagine.
Correct.
Zap Judah not released knocking
down Floyd. I'll tell you this.
If he did get knocked out a week before
the fight and you fight and hung Antonio
Saturday Bueno, we go and Sizzler,
I might just fucking no Bueno.
Omnipresent showtime.
Everybody.
I like the same story kind of happened
before the packout Mayweather fight and
uh, well maybe did it happened if it
said Florida flooring's Zap Judah denies
flooring. Mayweather doing
sparring is prepare shit.
Maybe they have Jesus, whoops,
his ass Uriah faber style. Probably so
comfortable with being there with Floyd.
He's box Floyd professionally as a
fighter and as training part true. Like,
you know, like you get each of other's
patterns. You understand those patterns.
Yeah. And who knows? Also,
you know like who knows how seriously
Floyd's taking this, that's the thing.
Need the money for sure. That's the
other thing is like rumors coming out.
Like again, these are all rooms. Have
you seen the condition rumors too?
I love the drama kids. So excited too.
I'm like, yes. Yes. What else happened?
Keep it coming. Come on. Um, have
you seen the picture of Floyd at 40?
It looks good. Good. I'm a fuck you. It
looks like he's on that Brock Lesnar.
He looks red and he looks great under 2.5.
Wow. Wow. Wow, wow, interesting. Um,
that's the only way
Mcgregor's going to win.
I think if it's under the two and a half
I'll, no, not in an under two and a half,
but by stoppage I think. Yeah, me too.
I can't imagine him out boxing. No,
that ain't happening yet.
You're living in a rung fucking planet
if you think you've seen to help box
around of them. Unless he figures
out a way to mall. I'm like,
he's done a style like he's doing there
with holding the back of the head and
throwing punches,
but that's after he's worn Paulie out.
I think you're going to see,
I think you see Connor using his footwork
still the distance trying to, you know,
still do what got him to the dance.
He might.
What if he drops one on Floyd
and Floyd go stiff face plants?
I would love that. I think he's going
to land one on Floyd. I think so.
I think Carter went, when's the
spectacle? The probably loses in decision,
but if there is a stoppage it's
Connor knocking them out. Well,
you know we're talking today about them
going to eight ounce gloves and how how
significant the official commission just
granted it. That first of all shows you,
you could just, you could just pull
those commissioners a silent go.
What's these rule drug testing?
Why are we talking about rules?
Let's have some fun here.
Let's have some fun.
I wonder if WME came along like when
they bought the UFC that like, oh, what?
What's, what do you saw the guy? Yeah.
What's we need? What's up with the Golden?
We got about another six months.
Can't we listen?
Let's just direct that guy
towards weight cutting.
Can you just have them like folks on the
guys than the undercarriage and we do
that. Hello? We get out of this.
You saw of them for
rentals backing up percent,
hundred percent when Andre Berto
said, when he fought Floyd,
he's never been tested more in his life.
He was like four times a
week they'd knock on my door.
Stop all dressed up like agents.
That's what he says. He goes,
are you testing Floyd like this?
They go, that's none of your concern.
He was just the promoters obligation as
the promoters. Floyd Mayweather. He goes,
you'll figure it out. He just
kept getting tested nonstop. Yeah.
He wants more of your blood. He wants
you to make you tired, you know? Yeah.
I'll tell you what though.
I don't know what the drug
testings like on this bad boy, but
it was interesting because he made
Connecticut down to one 50 you know they
fought at one 50 and can,
they always makes people to come to him
like you have to play by his rules and
his fight though. That's
what's so scary. Yeah.
That's why I tip my hat to Floyd because
he went to fight at one 54 that's like,
that's all right. That's
perfect for Connor. Yeah. I
will do a dance clubs. What?
The frills? Yeah. Yeah. We'll
do that. We'll do it all.
Take on short notice to
this motherfucker is crazy.
I just think he thinks he's so good.
He might just not understand
like first of all,
Connor is whether or not you'll look.
You're looking at his
success inside the octagon,
which had been pretty spectacular,
but it's the way he's doing things.
He's got this special fucking air about
him and this very psychotic belief in
himself. It's a D it's not
a fake belief. No, he's not.
He's not trying to con anybody.
He's trying to manifest like some
sort of miraculous existence.
He's trying to be the guy who literally
goes in there and drops and smashes
Floyd Mayweather as a UFC fighter and
then becomes with that the biggest athlete
on the planet earth. Ever. Maybe ever,
if he flatlines Floyd made in Fort Wayne,
where are there steps in
and Connor fucking karate
stance is ham and blast them
with a straight left hand and we see Floyd
stiffen up and face plant North Korea
nukes where we're going to turn
the ocean green shit. Okay.
We're all, we're going to
manufacture all of the color.
That green color that you put in
drinks on Saint Patrick's day,
pouring that shit in the ocean. We're
making the ocean green. Just all green.
Just huge statues of Conor.
You're going to have people
that are faking Irish accents.
That's sort of like that. Rachel
Dolezal chick pretended to be black,
is going to be people that are changing
but put a show on the beginning.
Agritech tattoos on their chest.
They're going to change themselves and
become Irish. They're going to be trans.
It'll get that. That's what the
world's going to done. What is that?
When did that happen? Cargo on Saint
Patrick's Day. They do that really?
Other fish.
Oh my God, we're so gross.
People are so gross.
Let's have some fun and get fucking
hammered it and make the ocean greed.
The fish are like, what the fuck? I
can't believe they really do this.
It's awesome though. Oh my God. It's
like a domino. It's only in Chicago.
I'm amazed that Boston doesn't take
this on. You're fucking battle in me.
They don't in fucking
Chicago. Really? Shit.
I feel like it's a bad idea can be,
well it's probably some food based stuff.
The family that dies the Chicago
River Green. Wow. The Hawk family.
How weird is pure toxic?
Yeah. Wonder how bad it is.
And one if there's like
some environmentalists that
are protesting or percent
that can't be great for anything in
there that's just died. It's natural.
Not really. Why don't you? Um,
Google environmentalist protest
green dye in Chicago River.
See,
let's see if there's some
environmentalists that
think it's fucking terrible.
I 60 pounds of die. That's it.
At top secret format. Awesome.
As we call it. Leprechaun dust. I'll fuck
you. How about you tell us what the fuck.
The top secret formula right
now with your tits tits.
The Dad on the right. Oh yeah.
Set of sweet old old man.
We get them and it's like a
mock turtleneck that looks
like the Kinda Guy who
kills a burger with his bare hands.
He looks like the kind of guy that kills
millions of fish by dumping green dye
in the Goddamn river. We get those
fucks. Fuck is drowned in mermaids.
I get their gills all clogged gut
leaky. Those guys got, damn it.
Yeah, you're right though man. If
God were to pull it off, I don't.
He's the biggest athlete of
all time. Oh, all the time.
He's going to be worldwide in
the in the craziest way possible.
You see a Nike shoe like to join,
but with this on it,
if he actually can land that shit,
there's the thing.
Nobody's gonna ever box Floyd like
that from a karate stance. Never.
He's never seen it before and he's been
doing a lot of that taekwondo footwork
thing where he switches back
and forth switches Stanson ton.
If he can keep that kind of distance,
it's going to be very hard
for Floyd to hit him too.
It's a totally different feel. Different
fields. The only thing I think,
worst case scenario, obviously worst
case you get starch in like 10 seconds.
That's not going to happen.
But worst case it would be with eight
ounce gloves and Floyd sarcs landing and
beating him up and he gets stopped like
seventh or eighth or can't answer the
bell cause he's taken so much
punishment or an eight rounds.
He gets really tired from Logan so much.
Then it could be a shit show for it.
It's a different expenditure
of energy for sure.
Different animals switching legs like
that and switches dances, but hey listen,
he's doing in training.
You don't get to counters level without
realizing what you're signing for.
It like to me,
if Carl were to gas in this fight,
there's a sear and then everything
we believe in commerce fake,
which I don't think it's going to happen.
While the only other explanation B,
he's not quite efficient enough yet
to go 12 rounds of the world champion.
You know if he really started gas like
you're talking about something that he
has a part of his training but it's
also kicking takedown down defense,
Jujitsu, elbows, knees and
some say is more down. Yes,
we'll definitely cardio was a lot of
people say it's more difficult like inbox
and get your rest and like in boxing,
which is why I think Conor is going to
win a majority of those early rounds and
you know Floyd, you know, four, five,
six rounds before he's really even start
sweating and he downloads your patterns
that goes to work.
The Andre Berto said that he goes,
he comes out and he'll force you to
come to him and he's looking around.
He's literally downloading everything,
but it takes them a while to get going
before he gets it and then starts going
to work with Connor. I think
in those rounds he can land
something big there. Man.
If he does see the exciting thing is,
if he does, that's exciting thing.
That's what, that's what's going to make
it the biggest paper view of all time.
Those white power people
are going to go crazy.
That Twitter account is a fake
account apparently. Which one? New,
it's not a real newspaper.
And some people I found out
that the picture is even
like a small business owner
from somewhere else. Which which uh,
the Zap judo, the troll doll account.
Okay. So the him knocking him
out, his fake. That's Dennis.
I told you, hey, hey boy
trolling the fake guy.
He looks like the average American.
You had to get shot Avatar or like Iowa.
You went to Iowa, you went to a
family restaurant. Hi, welcome.
They all look like go to Las
Vegas Post and nothing comes up.
Oh that son of a bitch.
Damn it flood.
You've got to do better at
selling this man. There's some,
while it might not even be him, it might
just be somebody just going for clicks,
you know, having some fun. A lot of
people make up stories. It's true.
Flood hasn't come out and say anything,
but you don't like my mom will be like,
why did he got knocked out and buying
it? It works. It does work well,
especially after looking at that video.
I mean that's what ramps it up.
Looking at the video of Khan
and landed on Paula, Dana White,
put some more video out. That's all
I'm saying. He has a full taste.
Here's the full footage from what I heard
from what I heard is they thought that
footage is going to make it an all
access. And Dana was like, yeah,
put in the all access of Connor doing
what he did to Paula and they didn't put
in there. So Dana was like release the
hounds and then released on his end. Oh,
so showtime didn't put it in there?
No, no, no. It came from Dana.
Did they not come from showtime?
Okay.
Why would show time not
want to put in there?
So they just denied putting it in there.
They didn't want to put it in there.
I don't think that, I don't, I don't
think they, they denied that ever happen.
They're just like,
we're not putting all access like for why?
I have no idea who put that in all access.
I don't know.
But that seems ridiculous. I don't know.
Are you trying to sell a fight or nay,
but yeah, and then Dana was
like, Yo, you're not going
to do it. Release the hounds.
Everybody real advocate.
That's when it came from his account.
Why the fuck would they not
play that clip? I don't know.
I guess they love Pauly Paul.
He's an analyst for them. Right,
but still it is what it
is. Yeah. If anything,
I listen man.
It's spine.
We talked and we're talking about
practice like it's, it is what it is.
[inaudible] loss those,
those,
those in those exchanges there was
a clear loser and a clear winner.
It doesn't mean the entire
sparring session. No,
and we won't know that
until after the fight.
And most knowledgeable fighting
fans know that like, oh, that's a,
that's a part of it. But shit,
Connor can actually hit like shit.
He looks pretty good.
He looks real.
And even if you're a box and paying like
holy shit, that's poly mail and nausea.
He just got rocked. Shit. Maybe
I won't buy the fight. Yeah,
it's given me a wake us, no
matter what, I'm going to buy it.
I'm going to buy it from fucking DC.
I'm going to be in Washington DC
to your work in the night, right?
Working that night. So if you
hear the crowd, oh my God,
if they asked me to do something
to the showtime, but I'd be like,
I don't even know what I would do.
Like what would I be doing?
Like it'd be offering my opinions. I
have none. I fly out next Monday for him.
I'm working,
I'm on the whole coverage team with
showtime Tuesday through Saturday.
I don't know what I'm doing on
Saturday yet. Honestly. Dude,
I really feel like if they were smart,
like this is this kind of like the kind
of shit that we do when you and I just
sit down and talk. This is
really what they need. Yes.
You get a bunch of goofy people sitting
around with ties on and some circle and
everyone's talking over everybody and
there's a production meeting and you say
this and you say this. I agree. Yeah.
And there's morrow and then there's a
fucking two or three boxers and everyone's
Bernstein and they're all talking over
each other. It's, it's uh, it's not,
in my opinion,
it's not the most entertaining way
to listen to people break down shit.
And this is a fight where you really,
you really want to consider all
the different possibilities.
Like Max Kellerman is always saying like,
Floyd has the advantage if they're
fighting on the moon, Floyd has,
he had managed bare knuckle Floyd as the
advanced. Like okay, you totally sure.
He totally sure Mr Skip Bayless method
where it's going to make headlines but
they don't have to believe that.
Macks believed that. I don't,
I don't think back to Lisa. I think
he's so, so old school boxing,
he has to say he loves him and may too,
man.
I've had long conversations with kind
of, but I think smart, he's very smart.
He's my favorite alias. I love
Max Guy. He's a very good note.
When I was in a favorite, you're
well, I'm saying boxing Komatsu.
Come on brother comes to box and when,
when when he goes, when he goes congress,
I can hit him and I was like, no,
just shred. I bet you $100,000 open,
a joint account sent to his team like
this. How seriously I got Atlanta Glove.
Oh really? Come with man, come on Mac.
It could happen that Floyd just storms
out and fucking one pudge chaos thing
with showtime. I had this uh, chat
with us when knows about it and I said,
I don't know what you know,
I don't be part of it.
I'm not sure where I'm gonna do.
I said,
but what you have going on as you have
your traditional box and commentators,
which is great and that's usually what
you do. This is not your typical fight.
You cannot have a bias panel who don't
know anything about Conor Mcgregor. Yeah.
They looked as fights up or whatever
or they just mimic or say what they've
heard previously, but they really
don't know what Connor's doing.
You have to have someone, whether it's me
or not, but I think it's going to be me.
You have to have someone telling you what
Connor's doing, what he needs to do to,
to win the fight.
You can't have just a pro bias box and
commentating team because what's going to
make this the biggest paper of all
time is the UFC fans. Of course,
we're the ones that are going to buy
this bitch, the old box and heads.
Look at triple g.
That's your best boxer.
200,000 paper view buys probably
300,000 that's your path.
But you know Andre Ward is right up there
with him and Andre Ward gets way more
now. He doesn't, they don't do very well.
Look up Andre Ward Kovalev to what it was,
the pace of the box.
275,000 that's it. But still a
hundred more than didn't triple g's.
Still pretty match of a huge fight too.
And I'm saying so the Dana White do UFC,
Conor McGregor,
that fan base to UFC fan base is
like nothing else man. They would,
I pay 100% true.
So you can't have just a bias box and
contained Kovalev does just over 160,000
oh my God, I'll put a picture of
me lifting weights in the back.
God hundred and 65,000 buys.
Wow.
So that's basically the
same as triple g in the,
in the ward Kovalev to does around
hundred 25,000 pay per view buys.
How crazy is that?
Is that which one's right?
Jalon ones July. Oh, the first
one versus the second one? No,
the second one does 125 it's a
paper loop flop. So the most it did,
it said it pulls in one 65 that was
the final thing, which is Tavon,
which is a leader or to that
magnitude of that fight.
No one is June 30th and it said one 25
and they still have June 27 160,000 the
second 125.0 no.
Really?
Oh my God. That's terrible.
So it's that stuff failure,
like you losing money when you do that.
And you paid Andre Ward, you know,
six and a half million dollars. Did he
get that much? Yeah. And that, you know,
you're talking about one of the best
fights of vault, especially the maze.
And the fight is amazing.
What was more troubling,
not only the pay per view buys down,
but attendance numbers.
And Kate Revenue at Mandalay Bay Events
Center in Las Vegas was not even close
to matching the first bout,
which is held at t mobile arena.
It's tickets sold 6,000
tickets. Whoa, that's crazy.
Wow. So if you're gonna make this
the biggest paper of all time,
you've got a bank on the mixed
martial arts crowd by his thing. Yeah.
So if you want them to buy it,
they're going to buy for coming anyways.
But you've got to have a voice in there
that's at least going to relate to
people. Yeah. And here's another
argument for the Andre Berto fight,
which was the retirement fight for Floyd.
He only got like 300,000 papers.
Horrible. Horrible. When you,
considering that he got 4 million
for the Manny Pacquiao fight, right?
Wasn't something crazy like that 4
million, which is the biggest of all time.
So he goes from the biggest of all time
to a fight worth 300,000 people buy it,
which is like really mediocre.
Horrible.
The only people are buying
Floyd Mayweather fights
or people that want to see
Floyd Mayweather. They get fucked up.
Yeah. And when he doesn't get fucked up,
they go, damn, they get upset. See, I love
even Floyd apologize for the pack yet.
But yeah, he was like, yeah, my
bat like that sucked. I that like,
that was not fun man.
It was crazy.
Cause Pat Guy was injured and then pat
out fought that fight with a fucked up
shoulder pack. Yes. Hating on
this fight. I won't even watch it.
I guarantee your ass it's more
entertaining than your fight with Floyd.
I can guarantee you that. He's just
still salty. Yeah. Cause he's not, he,
he just lost the fucking homeboy Horn in
Australia and you have to rematch him.
A school teacher straight up. Straight
up. That's the rich Franklin or boxing.
Yeah.
Just,
I don't know if that was the correct
decision because I didn't, uh,
I didn't try to score that. I see
both ways. I watched her twice.
I can see both ways, but, but uh, when
I was watching on my ground like door,
I'm like, God, I feel like corn might
have pulled that off. She's like, really?
I'm like, yeah, I can't listen
to the commentators. They're
soap bias against horn.
I feel like he might've did enough
or especially early on. I'm like,
I kind of bring it to him.
How many times they get dropped
once or twice horn in the,
I think it was the 10th round, they almost
stopped it because the Knight Eight,
ninth or 10th one of those
rounds, they were like, hey,
if you don't show some improvement here,
we're going to stop the fight.
So that was a rough round, but still the,
the, the culmination of all the rounds,
I thought horn pulled it off.
Interesting.
Either there's argument for either one
still pack. Yeah. He lost the horn.
You're going to hate on,
you know, Mayweather and
fucking Connor. Come on man.
You're gonna Watch it.
He's still salty because also he's got
class action lawsuits against him because
he fought with a fucked up shoulder and
a lot of people bet on you. Fucked us.
Yeah.
That's a weird situation.
If you're a fan and you know that the
guy came into the fight, compromise,
get that paycheck, but for
pay, but at the same time,
a lot of fighters fight with injuries.
Right. That's a big one though. I mean,
he's a puncher and his shoulder's
fucked. Like he can't throw. Hey Man,
what did he do?
I guess they schedule.
I wonder what they did they give them a
cortisone shot? What did they do? Yeah.
I mean we didn't do it, but
if you're manly packet, what
do you do? Just like, Hey,
I'm injured. We're going to
have to reschedule a slate.
Oh, I think he figured,
well, I'm going to fuck it up.
I'm going to get surgery anyway.
I just fuck it up further.
True.
Go in there and sling bombs and
hopefully our catch and did nothing.
Horrible fight. Well, it's just, I think
he was really compromised in his movement.
You know? I still don't think you'd beat
him, but, no, I don't think so either.
I think his style, and particularly as
much shorter and smaller than Conor,
and he's a very fast,
but you know,
he's also been knocked out by Manmohan
Marquez when Juan manwell mark has
knocked him out without one punch.
Fucking devastating lamb. Kao Earth,
like literally stood still for a
second when that happened. Dude,
I mean that was his clean
a one punch knock every
going to see my face. Yeah,
it was a horrible knockout.
Perhaps Marquez was on the
supplements of his home country.
I think all of them were. Yeah, I think
both of them. I think there's, you know,
steroids in that pitch.
I think there's Mexicans,
steroids and that was [inaudible] about
Manny is that Manny had gone up so many
different way classes and kept his
power and and people like, come on son.
He was like, get the fuck out. It's
probably gay. I don't hate on those guys.
I just assume he's doing it. I don't
hate on him either. I mean, look,
the deal is that a, you pass the
tests. That's the deal. Not Testing.
I don't give a fuck. You're fighting
Marquez. Who's clearly on those Tiawana
Tiawana Tamale fucking protein powder.
Is he alive?
Testosterone son? The
Teal on a test, you know,
100% if he got in that Filipino,
you know what's crazy is that dude,
I'm Juan Manwell Marquez
had the same trainer.
They used to be a trainer for Manny. Who's
the Guy Hooked Hook? What's the name?
Angel. Uh, I think it's Alex something.
I thought it was like ally
it something like that.
Really smart physical
conditioning trainer.
He had Manny doing a bunch
of really interesting stuff.
He's very good. Very good.
But he got picked up before he got
busted before for like injecting the Bain
stuff. Yeah. He got in trouble before the,
it was at the same dot guy that got in
trouble. Like that's his thing. Right?
Like that's what he was known for.
I know he's supposed to be a really
good trainer regardless. Well you know,
I mean you kind of think when you
got a guy like a Floyd or one men,
Mel Marquez or you know anybody or Manny,
you got like a championship
caliber athlete. You know,
you got like you had a Ferrari.
Yeah.
I mean you gotta make
sure the tires are good,
suspensions tight and like you're
a physical conditioning trainer.
You can't fuck the guy up too bad. By the
time he gets to his boxing skill work,
you don't want him to be that exhausted.
But also if we're racing
cars and you know,
homeboy over here put up feet 12 in his,
he can't be running with a v 10
maths V12 we've got to manage that.
Let's get that Filipino hot sauce. Yeah,
like that's, that's the game though.
Yeah,
I would man.
He was in his prime to God
whatever him judge Jack Jack Shit.
And I remember he was like get strip
clubs, like wiling out very Jon Jones Ish.
And then his wife was like,
this shit has to stop and
then got flashlight and he's
like, Jesus, let's do it.
Yeah.
He found the g's are stressing all weird
for government and changed his life.
Changed his life. I don't know if
that's the best thing for fighters, man.
Oh, who knows? It's a problem as,
especially now with testing, you know,
they show up at your house and knock
on the door. You gotta be clean. Yeah.
You got a rubber dick and a really
good friend. Even missing blood.
Even then you're in trouble, man. Yeah.
You got to have a twin and have that
twin like live a steady healthy diet.
I don't just don't tell anybody about him.
Just leave him in the basement.
Look at them. They're against Marcos
Antonio, Bruh. Do I got pissed so bad.
Can I pee right way? Hold it down. Super
jacked there. There's ones where you list,
he's looked jacked.
Damn Jack there too.
That's the other Floyd
fight. Yeah. When it,
when he was like, when he first
started out he was, I think he was,
I think he started out as a
flyweight like I'm not sure though.
I'd have to look at is a career record
pull up Manny Pacquiao is career record
cause I'm pretty sure he went through
eight different weight classes,
which is crazy.
Really stop and think about that.
I don't think very many
people have done it. So, oh,
this is boring for a podcast which is
going over stats of Manny Pacquiao.
Who the fuck knows what's
going to happen? Man. That.
What's interesting is that
it's actually going to happen.
I'm just a big fan of
freak shows and that's,
and I don't mean that
disrespectfully like that.
It's not a real contest obviously.
Obviously it is from a betting perspective
and obviously it is because Connor is
a real combat sports world champion,
but it's a freak show in that it's,
we don't know.
It's not like,
like if Connor fought Hofeld dos
Anjos at one 70 it's a fight like,
Ooh, this is going to be interesting.
I wonder how that's gonna play out.
I wonder if it's,
you know,
they were supposed to fight at one 55 I
wonder if Tilson Joe's can fit, you know,
that kind of thing happens.
That's an interesting fight.
That's interesting to think about.
You have all these variables.
You've seen their fights.
Now we're seeing Connor box.
You see like little tiny clips.
That's all he ever see.
When's the last time where there's a
fight like this where it's like made like
by the people I don't
think ever UFC at all.
Ever while there's James
Tony Versus Randy coture.
But James was well past
his prime and you know,
really didn't train for it at all.
He didn't know. I mean there was,
it was a video,
James toney preparing for the Randy coture
fight and he was way out of shape and
it was just kind of like hitting pads
and the guy who like shoot the worst
double leg take down on
them and the history of the
known universe and James had
kind of sprawl and he be like, yeah, and
we're going to my rambling, you know,
working on my box and no one
on my box where's on my boxes.
And they said he barely trend for the,
but that's the blocks in next week's like,
I mean it's like James,
Tony come in your welding. No, it's
not. It's fucking not out of shape.
Didn't respect the game. Yeah, just
kind of was doing it for the paycheck.
It's like if Anthony Joshua gets,
you know,
if he's got an actual black
belt in Jujitsu we don't
know about and then decide
to fight MMA. But he's all
right. And Steve, but he's
already Anthony. Joshua. Yes.
Yeah. That's really what it's
about. That's what it's like.
It's like how's he going to deal with
kicks? I was going to deal with that.
That's where it's a lot.
There's some x factors like I don't know,
but I know he does these two things
very damn way and he's super good at
knocking people dead. Yes. Yeah.
I think that's one of the things
that guy does like that's,
that's a real threat he's at in his prime.
He's 28 years old.
It's a real threat and you know
[inaudible] he's going to do it. Yeah.
Like the comes is he 100% believes
he's going to win this fight,
which is when you got a guy like that
and he has momentum on his side and you
get the fucking nation of Ireland
behind your God and man at some game of
Thrones special shit.
And also Floyd legitimately is almost
41 like I think he might be 41 at the
fight.
Like I think like his birthday happens
between like what's his birthday like he
might be 41 now and he's in training camp.
He turned 41 that find out what it is.
That's true. Release on Instagram though.
I was like, he does not look 41 yeah,
he's great. February. Okay. So
he's real close, whatever it is.
So when he gets to be whatever the age is,
when the wheels fall off it,
that's the thing.
Who knows what happens if he gets dinged,
I think he will be slower.
And because if it's Floyd in its heyday,
yeah, Kinda didn't stand a chance.
But Floyd notch slower man.
Well you remember my Donna,
you know Donna came in fucking
winging bombs at Floyd. Yeah.
And the first fight Floyd kind of,
I think maybe there were underestimated
him or didn't understand like the like
the style that he was going
to present and he got clipped,
he got clipped with one punch at the
end of one of the rounds where his legs
wobbled and I was like, whoa. And then re
matter of Floyd did the rematch, cad it,
pick them apart. What's, he downloaded
it but oh yeah, I see. Matt just made it,
didn't take him serious.
It's possible or it's possible.
My Dawna fought really well and the first
fight and didn't fight so well in the
second fight for various reasons. Yeah.
But the only thing with that is Connor,
so much different than May Donna.
It's way more skillful and he's also,
he's very capable of doing weird shit.
Like at a distance. His ability to move
in and out is very crisp. You know,
it's like you have to,
you have to respect it.
Like what he did to f two Josie Aldo slid
back and drop that left hand in silly.
That's not something a lot of people
are capable of doing under fire. No, no.
Especially the what? The stakes and
your margin of error and the mixed,
my shot just so much smaller
than boxing. It's just, you know,
it's his timing that makes him special
in his time and we'll be better than
Floyd's.
Floyd's can be a little slower.
I just think cottage timing with
the speed and power. That's why,
that's why I give them a shot.
If Floyd sleeps on him at all and
Connor comes in and does something very
unusual and catches flow
with a big punch early,
it could be chaos with eight ounce calls.
How about Floyd? You're crazy, man. Well,
here's the thing.
MMA fighters fight with four ounce gloves.
So like why is boxing decided that eight
ounces are what's safe for everybody?
135 pounds and up 10 ounces,
eight ounces would say for
anybody 135 pounds down.
So that's like only a few weight classes.
It's not shipped.
But also those boxing gloves, man,
10 ounces when he got the wrap on.
I mean if you have clubs under hands,
man,
literally clubs just protect me
from breaking it. That's 10 ounces.
Yeah. Interesting. It makes
us so interesting. Yeah.
It becomes like an MMA fight
more [inaudible]. It's not,
it's going to be real weird.
It's got to be real weird until
we see what happens when you know,
we might see Floyd pick them apart.
Yeah.
And that the how the odds are that's going
to happen by just, I don't see it man.
If he really does start fighting like
this though. Ooh, that would be weird.
If Connor starts doing this, doing
that, you're going to see it.
It's going to be those,
those first four rounds people,
hopefully whoever you're watching with,
there's just silence.
Just what in the fuck
are we seeing right now?
What Floyd is also a counter
striker and so it was Connor,
but if Connor starts doing some weird
karate shit and get some on its heels,
gets some moving back and it's somehow
or another can get them into some weird
position where he can move faster than
Floyd understands or he could close the
distance quicker than Floyd expects. I
listen, I ask Polly, I go to poly. I know,
I know you guys hate each other,
all that, but when you're sparring,
would there things that were landing
because he did some things that were
unexpected and definitely landed. I'm
like, man, that's the thing with Connors.
If he's gonna, if he has that in his bag,
his bag of tricks, when he throws it,
it has to count because as soon as you
throw it Floyds and go, got it downloaded,
downloaded, how many do you
have? Four. Five over 12 rounds.
You better make them fucking count,
man. Yeah. It's like yet five bullets.
You better, you better hit the
target man. Yeah, it's true. Right?
Right.
And here's the other thing.
How Brittle or Floyd's hands really
pretty brittle, broken them a few times,
right? But it was a huge factor from if
you've ever seen, uh, like his training,
stuff like that.
After every session is hands on pure ice
and they had some [inaudible] at night
massage his hand. So it's obviously
a factor, right? Let's say that was,
was that before his last fight?
If Roberto was,
what else been going on for quite
some time. I still get sore. Yeah.
So think about this.
Eight ounce gloves.
He hits Conor in that giant Irish
head that the has a forehead.
Let's be real. It's good looking. Doobie
has a dome on him. He hits that hand,
breaks his hand. Ooh, we go and Sizzler,
certain factors I like to bank on that's,
I'm recognizes that his hands
broken and he starts talking to him.
But all you have is a jab and he starts
Shumlin put his hands behind his back.
Broke your fucking hand,
your fork to your book.
Your fucking hand didn't hit a little
core and get lit head to can you imagine?
And then he just inoculates Floyd just
walked him down. That's an interesting,
like people were really mad at
him for calling Floyd boy. Oh Man.
He can call each other bitch motherfucker
don't say boy this song cause Oh,
do you know Joe? You? Yes. My boys were
boys with Andre Birthday. I was like,
I kept saying homeboy don't, when he
left I was like Mass Jack. No racist.
Hashtag homeboys okay.
Yeah. Homeboys like,
oh he's my homeboy. Hey homeboy,
you got to really figure this out.
It's weird though cause it has boy in it.
Like you can't have any pause between
home and boy. Oh home boy. Yeah.
He can't say that to a black guy.
No, it's too much boy. And it's too,
I gotta be careful man. Cause like with,
with Berto, he said something like,
Oh that's my boy. It's hard to
say triggered around a black guy.
Trigger trigger. Trigger. Why?
Because it sounds like, yeah,
right. Yeah. You're like any word
that's close. I said tre, tre,
tre. I said tea bro.
[inaudible] rigor. Yeah.
Boy You just can't.
Yeah you can't.
You can't like did you see Cody Garbrandt
kept calling? Uh, sterling boy, boy,
two boys. A weird one. We just got to take
it out though. You like on social media.
Can't do that. But why not will
cause the, I mean, come on Joe.
It's weird but cool.
But here's the thing,
if aljamain started
talking shit about Cody,
that boy can't touch me no problem at all.
I know.
See I don't have a problem with that.
Crazy. No one has a problem with it.
Well but black people can
use the n word in boy. Right?
Cause they kinda that like they went
through some shit to earn that title.
But boy, but he, boy, we used to be fine.
It wasn't fine though.
Right?
Boy was probably always used
like especially down south
as a derogatory term for
young black men. Oh, the white people
would always, hey boy. Hey boy,
over here. All those fucking Home Depot
candle carrying douchebags fucked up. Boy.
It's a fun word to great words. Those are
my boys now. I can't say that anymore.
Definitely say that I have a nine.
The token black guy, those are my,
those are my men. Hang out with white
people just for that reason. All lights,
all whites. I get Charlottesville.
Fucking, yeah, but Ian Edwards,
I can ever say Ian's my boy. Nope. That's
not the window. No, but with, with Cody,
I don't think Cody's racist. He was like,
wait, I boy keep fighting. Like again,
you got to know the connotation.
You've got to know you're
talking to a black guy,
so just don't use it like just
a minute. Youth Bro. Right?
Like if you say that craze, why
you guys own bro? You we, we did,
but it used to be a black guy thing. No,
no. Sub Brow. Nope. Black guys own Bra.
No, no, no. That's new, Bro.
Was like the 70s back when
they had platform shoes on
and fucking bell bottoms.
Now see, I feel like Becca said brother,
they had brother and bro. What up Bro?
It really Ross like surfer like that.
Yeah,
but no, it's like Hawaiian. Your br eight.
I'm talking B u h Bruh, Bruh.
Ay Bro. Hold up bro. Yeah,
that's like from ice tea. I think
he probably invented that. Correct.
So then they own it. Or should I say ice
cube? Which one? Ice Cube or ice teas.
A little older. You know what I'm saying
though? Like there's different bro. Man.
White people fucked up bro though.
Races became like a guys who were
like loafers go to private schools
at Bro. Yeah, maybe like
the Frat Boys Bros. Yeah,
like guys try a little too hard but not,
yeah,
now it's a bad connotation
because he'd go, oh my God,
it's such a bro is over there.
I'm like the crazy bros.
Like as soon as someone goes, oh, they're
such bros, like, oh, I get it bro.
Science all the time with Joe
Rogan's using bro Science.
Vegans love to say that,
bro. Science. We know
exactly what boroughs.
It's a funny thing,
but it's,
it's anti male and a lot of
ways and it's really rude.
They,
they get upset if you mock anyone that's
transgender or anyone that's w a woman
or anyone that's gay,
but they have no problem calling us bros.
Yeah,
we've got no problem shitting on the
very essence of being a man is throw him
out, Bryan out Bryan and now
I'm embarrassed to say it then.
It's toxic masculinity, man. It's toxic.
I mean if I post a picture
of his podcasts and went,
me and my Bros were getting roasted and
getting roasted the borough squad, Bro.
It it out.
Didn't used to be that way.
It's become that way over the last few
years when so many douchebags use bro.
We did it to ourselves.
We did to ourselves.
A lot of tools did it cause they took
it over and used it here it's not.
We were being generous and including
ourselves and the rest of the men who
fucked it out real. We didn't fuck
it up. I feel like we made it cool,
but we use brother now. That's my
brother. Yeah, brother to other can work.
Brother's like, you can't just do the
term brother around a guy barely know.
Tonight I will be like,
oh, what's up brother?
You can't do the tricky unless you're
hulk Hogan unless you like so friendly.
You want everybody to be your brother
like Ooh, okay. It could be that guy, man.
I don't trust that he's his
brother just with anyone.
Can I throw it around a lot? If I'm
high from high and I meet strangers,
so rather you don't have to
meet and greets. I say, Bro,
what's up brother? Yeah,
I see. That's different, right? He
experienced something with them.
They saw your show. I know a little bit
different brothers and the way in a way,
hey man, what do you think about
this? Tony Ferguson. Kevin Leafy.
That's a good God damn fine. I love that
fight. Kevin Lee is a bad motherfucker.
We took Michael Kia says back and
strangled him like he choked him. Yes,
I was upset.
Maybe maybe he would've survived,
but the bottom line is that shit was
locked up and it should've never gotten
locked up.
Well where I come from when you go like
this and you and then your body goes
limp and your bath to go out.
While he was saying,
and he was just concentrating on his
neck just flexing his that yeah, me too.
I was pretend I was asleep when they'll
get a punch me in the face. But no,
for real.
Like if a guy's really good at getting
choked and he can figure out how to kind
of Tuck his chin and flexes and the neck
and just ride out the choke and if he
thinks he's got enough air
or naked and Kevin Lee,
Kevin Lee is a straight up strangler,
like that's a strong fucking dude neck.
100% I know. I know. Black
belts, man, you get there,
you get there and the cheese is, is a
black belt young. He's a high level.
That's not a black boy. He's not
ranked, but he's essentially grappler.
I believe he has black belt
level in the UFC. Yeah,
that's it. He's a black belt
level grappling. The UFC,
that's fair to say. Oh yeah.
I definitely think it's a black belt
level. I know it's high level competition,
black belts,
where if a blue belt gets on your back
and they have a full sunken and rear
naked choke, there's not much you're
going to do. You can hand fight.
But if you had to actually in your fuck,
especially a strong athletic guy,
Kevin Rooney, I get Kevin Leon this
and I love Michael. He's a beast.
I like all his fights.
I just feel like Kevin Leman,
I think that the division needs him to,
he dresses well speaks well.
He's exciting to watch,
you know,
100% he's just that the mistake that
Mario made and stopping that fight before
an absolute conclusion is a big mistake.
Oh, Mario fucked up. That's just a joke.
It's a choke. You gotta let
when you have to let us know,
we have to have this argument
and then Kevin least like, Nah,
just choking him out cheap.
James is arguing. It wasn't
like you fucked up Mario.
Okay. Damn it. Because if Cassa
just did go out unconscious,
then we've got no debate.
And then Kevin Lee has this amazing
clean win and there's no bullshit to me
though. It was amazing clean wound and we
just moved on and went Mario fucked up.
But he was going out anyways.
What's an accept that?
Accept it because they went from
fighting and stony first. No they did.
And she has a, you're on the undercard.
It's a good move too because Tony and um,
Kevin Lee were John back and forth to
each other, you know, that's a good fight.
Very good fight. Kevin. He's a beast
and he's a young guy and he's one,
he's one of those guys that like you
see from his first fight in the UFC,
see this giant leaps every here.
So yeah, it was a big leap.
Calcify thought was going to give him a
lot of problems when he took him down,
got his back. I was like, Jesus Christ,
man and castle and the left hand on him.
But when I watch it over in the replay,
you know,
sometimes when you've
seen it live to your,
I'm looking through the
fence and look at it happen.
It's hard to tell what lands it
doesn't land. He moved away from it,
mostly caught on the end of it,
moved away from it and then you know,
once they got to the ground
it was crazy that he took yes,
his back and he dominated the position.
Super dominant.
The other thing is I find interesting
is Kevin Lee, one day he wants to fight,
compete after we fight for the past
three fights like I want to be in Russia.
It's like taking an asteroid superstar,
chill sun. Well that's the way to do it,
man. You know, asked to fight the scariest
fucking guy in the game, you know.
But the thing about Khabib is I don't
know where his body's out when they're
saying his liver shutdown when
he was supposed to be fighting.
Tony talks about a different
game. Yeah. What does that mean?
Like so much weight and his body literally
was shutting down if I'll fucking
Russian goes to the
hospital before a fight.
We got some serious problems,
serious problems.
He didn't cut weight right
and cut too much too soon.
And it's not even that they cancel the
five round fight for the interim title
and have a three round fight for a catch
weight. They don't even do that though.
You can't fight. The commissioner was
like, Nah Man, it's liver shutting down.
This is why when people are like, oh,
we got, could be Bruce Connor next.
Let's just talk about that. Logistically.
You've got a guy who can't make weight,
almost died making the way you can go
on a world tour against the biggest name
ever and mixed martial
arts and Conor McGregor.
That's going to be your fight and you
think college is going to commit to that.
How could he do that? Why would he,
why would you do that? Not only that,
Michael Johnson fight with Khabib
apparently at the same issue,
but he got through it
like they're saying this,
the same thing that happened
in the Michael Johnson fight.
So this means like as every wait cut
you do, especially as you get older,
apparently your body resists like a
sponge. He gets bigger and bigger.
It gets harder and harder.
You body does not want to do it every
time you get fat as fuck in between fights
too.
You know it was hilarious.
Cotsen Ghana was talking about chicks
like gaining weight in between fights
about you cut all that weight for file,
fuck your body up.
Like for a woman getting that
low in weight and body fat,
it's probably even more fucked. The
thyroids are fucked. Like, ah, my brother,
my sister in law,
my brother's wife,
she did calm petitioners cut
weight and her thyroid light,
it just fucks their bodies up.
Oh.
When they're doing a
bodybuilding competition with
of all that water weight and
height for the girls,
like you know some of these girls you'll
see in the EOC like the day of the
fight, like God, that's a supermodel. You
see her three weeks say like, God damn,
it looked like a Dell right now that like,
how did,
like they just blow up like it's literally
like their bodies while the body just
probably really resist that weight cut.
It's just not, it doesn't want to do it.
Like, probably your body goes into famine
mode. You know, he starts thinking,
we've got to retain some water on this
bit that's looking for that cyborg fight.
Cyborg is trying to fight Holly and Matt
Square Guard and that's a big fight.
That's a duck cyborg two days ago. And
she's like, man, Holly mascular gun.
That's what I want. Well that's a
try yet where there's some money.
You know what I mean?
The Holly is coming off the DRN
Germane to Rhonda may fight with Joe.
She's still, she's coming off down to
amend the hock, the banks. I betcha.
Yeah, but, but what, but batch go, hey,
I was really not in their league
in my opinion. Not at all.
Whereas your main Miranda may is she
cracked your main to randomly with that
high kick and then dropped her
with that straight left hand.
Like Jermaine Duran to me is as legit
as Stryker as you're ever going to see
men's MMA. So she's not fighting
Cyborg. She's Holly to drop her.
She just didn't want no part of that.
Have you ever seen anything like
that ever in mixed martial arts?
And I didn't try.
Damn,
I'm just went radio silent fucking six
months and they came back like she did
stuff like 10 years ago.
I'm gonna cut down a fucking one 35 when
I was talking to her post fight and I
said,
well what about Cyborg?
You know I was asking her and doing the
post fight interview and she's like, man,
I'm going to get some surgeries on
my fucking hand hurts right now.
Let's talk about this later.
Juncker question though. Right?
You do have a hurt hand, which I
believe she probably absolutely did.
Now's the time to do it.
Like, Hey I got this title.
I definitely know when I have
one hand if you're fighting.
But she did it do anything right.
She was like Nah,
that was an excuse she might have. But
she vacated the title cause you're like,
no, I'm not going to do that.
Holly fighting against soon. Yeah,
that class she fighting that she vacate
the belt was like Nah, we're good side.
We'd have fun up there.
Holly for Cyborgs and answering fight
cause I think stylistically Holly's the
perfect matchup to beat Cyborg. I don't
think she beats her, but style wise,
she's made to beat Cyborg. Thinking
about this, let's just go through,
think of Holly Beats Sideboard.
Whoa. She's aggressive. Make my shot.
Female mixed martial artist of all
time. Merck. Rhonda with a head kick.
So she beats the greatest.
Something's grades all the time.
Mercer goes on a little bit of a
tough run. Who gives a fuck then?
Beat sideboards. So beat Ron and Cyborg.
We're going sizzler. Yeah. And then me,
she'd take, comes back, get get you some.
She's whipping her ass for five rounds
and then just got choked out at the end.
But think about it and then you beat
Ronda who was undefeated at them.
Then you beat Frickin sidebar.
If she beats cyborg and me,
she comes back and fight her again.
That's a giant fight.
It's a giant fight with me. She
wants to fight again. She wanted,
but she would do it for that. Sitting
around Superfight that itch the tonight.
Katie Lang poured and poured a shit.
Itchy.
Fuck. We state still first team all
I'll qd up there. Oh yeah, yeah.
First team booty hit.
Hey, there was a recent,
those UFC titties, UFC to ties those.
Those are some period you'll see.
But with the Holly, if
Holly can somehow, again,
I don't think she's going to, but you
never know. I didn't, you know who?
I didn't think she was
really going beat Rhonda.
But if she somehow can pull off
beat Cyborg and she beat Rhonda,
did they do we just give her like some
weird statute for the UFC gym now?
Like how's this work?
Either they'll net but you know,
don't you think that in their eyes
like there's always going to be,
even though she beat Rhonda,
like Rhonda is the one that
put the thing on the map.
She's always going to be revered more.
You asked. See, I don't think so.
I think she has such a crash landing
like the worst of all time and she's gone
radio silent that we don't
remember that that climb.
Do you think people are upset and hurt?
Like you weren't really a fighter,
like you're only fighter for a little bit.
If you are really a fighter,
you'd still be there.
He'd be getting back into it.
You're still young people no matter what.
No matter what people,
where would that kind of shit matter
what they thought you were one thing and
you fail at it. You fucking loser. I know.
They get mad if you were
their hero for sure,
and you're not doing
what they want you to do.
Or you talked about
being a do nothing bitch,
and now you get knocked out and you're,
you're doing nothing. You know, it's like,
how dare you. I bought the shirt. She
was hosting battle of the network stars.
No, I don't. Dunno. I don't
know man. I don't know.
She's just not into it, you know? I mean,
I could see not wanting to find anymore.
Right. You didn't want to fight anymore
at a certain point in time. A little,
little different though. You
know, she was a world like,
she accomplished a lot more
than me. Um, you know, I, I,
I love my life now has never been better,
man. Like I love what I'm doing. I,
you know, I don't know. She doesn't
have a thing like, no Mary, no.
Maybe it was battle of the network stars.
I don't know if that's even true.
Calling. I can't believe they talked
to him to doing that. I Dunno man.
You know and also made me,
she made so much money like maybe
she's good there too. I don't know.
But even if you make so much money,
it's not about the money is it?
Everybody thinks that that's going to
be enough to make you happy. It's not.
It'll definitely be you in a position
where you don't have to worry about bills.
Now. Maybe that's your number one problem
and then you're going to be happier.
That's possible. Once you check that
off, the other prompts start to come up.
All right, well now what am I going
to do? Like I don't have a passion.
What am I waking up for?
There was a study on income and they,
well one of the things they said was
when it comes to like overall happiness,
see if we could find this.
I think they said everything
over $70,000 a year.
It's kind of a wash at 75,000 right
range and like going from, if you grew
up from a bike to a car and happiness,
when you go from a car to just buy another
car and you have two cards, nothing,
nothing changes in your, that's
not true. I agree with Trump.
My corvette and I agree that the fuck
you talking about the perfect salary for
happiness,
a $75,000 a year.
When did depend where you live and
what you like to do. Yeah. See,
I dunno about that. For like the
magic income, as people earn more,
their day to day happiness rises
until you hit $75,000 after that.
It's just more stuff
with no gain in happiness
that someone who's never
had a really cool record,
he never like had a deck that overlooks
the mountain. We real with your buddies,
he never been able to go on these dope
ass vacation and had a stake in a day
traveling to Japan, get some Sushi
fresh out of the fucking ocean rise,
some master chef, that private jet, you
can have some ball times. Hell yeah. Yeah.
Maybe you get a fucking yacht,
your rent it and go through the Caribbean.
Come on,
you do whatever you want to get kids.
He'd take it on vacation wherever you
want. You don't worry about that stuff.
The fuck out of here.
You trying to say Shit,
Dr Phil be just as happy if
you made 75 miles an hour.
It just depends man. Bitch.
Like when you study bro. Yeah.
You think Elon Musk be super pumped
to go down to about 75,000 a year?
I think Oprah has fucking get away cars.
We can save 5,000 year.
Do you think you would get
that top shelf actress pussy.
If he was making 75 million
a year or 75,000 a year,
he gets a million a year.
He would be like, damn,
I'm struggling [inaudible] 75
mil cut back on my security.
They were detailing all the different
shit that Johnny Depp's spends money on
too and it's just like this stuff.
What in the holy fuck he is.
I don't know what he does in
terms of his substance of choice.
That would what he enjoys the
appears to be on a financial rampage.
Then they have to like take out a loan
from his agent or some shit like that.
He owns Johnny Depp owns like
40 houses or something crazy,
something close houses all over the world.
They said it's security is like stupid,
like $275,000 a month.
Like bro, Bro, you just need one
guy who was trying to kill you.
He's an animal man. You're
fucking captain. Jack Sparrow
knows trying to kill you.
He's a fucking animal and he's got some
sort of a a million a month spending.
Well, you know, can I
spend money bro? Oh my God.
Johnny Depp's x business managers
that led, she has outrageous spending.
Happy of 2 million a month.
You get chose Johnny Depp.
You go get yours, dude.
How does that happen?
How does knowing go show you kinda chill
out on the 2 million a month he spent
$3 million to fulfill friend hunter s
Thompson's dream of having his ass shot
out of a cannon.
But that 1,000,045 luxury cars,
$10 million a year to support his
entourage, friends and family,
and $30,000 a month alone
on why he's awesome Buhler.
He's lived a great life though.
A matching those months.
2,000,045 luxury cars.
10 is osh.
Raj is having a grand old time
personal lawyer, Jake bloom.
Dep was living beyond his
means and urgent earn.
Urged him to spend less and sell certain
expensive but unnecessary assets to
repay loans and pay his
taxes and living expenses.
He's just out of 14 houses. Listen,
that's cocaine living right there.
At least in [inaudible] 14
residences acquire, improve,
and furnish.
14 residences.
I'm trying to see that car collection.
1414 residences,
45 luxury cars. Good Lord. How much
money did he make in his career?
I owe 650,000 fit million. Sorry, Jesus.
650 million. That's a lot of money,
but 2 million a year in the past 30 years
earned him an estimated $650 million.
Being a rich movie star over does not
necessarily bring great financial savvy
over the past decade.
Mr. Debt paid more than 65.6 million
in interest on overdue taxes,
has lent millions of dollars to people
unlike you to pay him back and has shit
and widely splurge. Just,
I love that word. Splurge.
Just a number of questionable investments,
not the least of which is
that town near central pay.
He bought a town.
My man just said,
we're balling the town called my
manager telling me buying a town.
The assistant calls the manager
John Johnny's buying the town.
He doesn't talk to the man. He was
like not so which house do you like?
I liked them all. I'll take the time
at home. I'll take all have homes. Oh,
crazy as that.
But he owns a street in Hollywood.
I was like a bunch of
like Stan hopes his boy.
I say that because they're both white
and Stanhope cost to go up the street and
there's a dude with an earpiece waiting
for him and the dude with the earpiece
takes from a golf cart and drives them
up to the top of the hill and they own
like the whole fucking block.
But there's one dude on the block that
apparently won't sell type move to that
guy. That guy's like, Nah,
fuck it. I like this house
forever.
Fuck off type move all coked up.
What's a buy it and improve accuracy.
It's just make the whole thing just
you're going to sail the seven seas and it
turn it black. The whole room
black. The whole house. I heard,
I heard Nicholas cage
is even crazier spin.
He buys castles and like Ma
Knight's equipment and chill.
It's good move him and Leonardo Dicaprio.
I think we're bidding on some skull
and he had to return it because it was
stolen or I'm like to him, I
forget where I look. That's bald.
When he bought a skull from King Tut's
fucking in the header return in the
museums or art,
that's our shit.
Leonardo Dicaprio had returned a bunch
of art that was given to him by a guy who
apparently was stolen.
All he agrees to return stolen
dinosaur skull to Mongolia.
Oh, that makes me feel good.
Using stupid purchases.
Skull of a tyranosaurs. What does it,
what does that word? Tyron source.
But Tara, what is that? What's
a tyrannosaurus but tar?
Do you know what that is?
Have you ever heard that
before? No. How weird, Bro.
How much did those go for dude?
We were talking about, Whoa,
that's a dope looking animal. He
bought the Horace. Horace. Wow.
That must be massive.
So someone stole it,
someone stole it and he bought it and he
had to return at the black market. Wow,
that's crazy. Where do you put that in
your house? Where do you put it? Okay,
so here's my thinking.
You have to have a real skull.
Like if you want to buy some replica,
like a child's toy,
you're a fucking asshole.
Have you have one of those things?
You know how like fuck you.
It's that real. How dear
you, that's what I'm saying.
Like if you go to a lot of museums,
a lot of the skulls,
you're seeing a replica's damn
276,000 better deal. And I thought,
what? That's it, Joe, we need went for
the new studio Biden. I'm thinking,
let's make some bids on a t rex.
Let's just have like three
raptors at the new studio.
Do how much they ain't get about it.
How many,
what's like the most common domus dinosaur
they get by? I bet something lame.
But you get like a stegosaurus or chimp
because they're fun. Him a little heads.
The other begins.
They're all small.
They have little head and you
want to try say tops. Damn.
They'll saber tooth ones are bullshit.
We ain't trying to have that. Yeah.
Saber Tooth Tigers on dinosaur. Jamie.
That doesn't, that doesn't count.
Make sure they're real. Jamie
fives is got a son. Etsy.
Hey, free shipping. Free Shipping.
$55,000 what is it? What are they saying
they have? What does that, uh, that one.
What is the,
the animal that they can't
be real authentic fossil
Masa Sore Halley Saurus am
Bowl Amborella g m Borghi
to deadly duty studio.
Yeah, that does look pretty dope.
What is that thing? How big is it?
78 inches long,
dude.
Fucking is that real?
That's real.
They really have that for sale and
we get free shipping right now.
That's the thing with
Nicholas Cage's things.
So it took like seven years for him to
get to the certificate of authenticity
and then when they got it,
that's it and they found out it
was stolen by some fake shit.
Not Know for a while they had a dope ass.
Well,
there's one you can get a t
rex room 1.8 million. Yeah.
I just can't imagine that for 55,000
bucks you should get her. You get a real,
is that what it is? How much
was it? 250 50 55 free shipping.
Not about launching a t.
Rex is 1.5 million.
If I was like some salt and type
character, I'd have all that.
I'll run my house like game
of Thrones or a t rex go, oh,
scroll up 1.8 million.
Wow worth it.
If you're Warren Buffett, did those
go up and your worth 80 billion rides.
Like when I have a bunch of that shit
in your house by the shit out of that,
your wife would just slowly start
to realize you're going insane.
Start constructing a dinosaur in the
middle of the living room and he all of a
sudden construction crews at the house
like, what's what's going on, honey? Oh,
y'all raising the roof. I tried a new
t rats comedy. Rex. He's too tall.
We're going to have to
cut out the ceiling.
Every room I'm going to put
in glass ceiling out of stock,
out of stock.
That means somebody who bought it and
philosophy out there from Jurassic Park,
but I want to, I don't want to rubber
toy Janky. You know what I want to,
I'll take that Predator thing though.
I will take that. What did the,
how about this head? Oh, I know
a dude who makes those man.
The guy who made the American
Werewolf Patrick Miguelito,
he met a Predator and he makes the
alien. Those can't be you. Ooh.
Should we get that through?
Got a limo.
It's trying to pull it up.
White diamond premium white diamond.
It'd be an asshole. The vibe fish for a
million and a half dollars. That depends.
What's it? Is it alive? What's he do?
What is it? Is it a car? I'm seeing fish.
The most exclusive breed in the world.
Premium white diamond fish are rare
than precious gem stone. Oh my God.
So it's one of those things. If you're an
asshole, you have it in your fish tank.
Let Jeanette is one point $5 million.
Just white fish.
I did. Yeah. Currently there's
only like a hundred of those.
If you have an all white moose at your
house, he's getting some panty dropper.
Here's the thing, man. Here's the real
thing. If you're on a hunting trip, okay,
that moves is a legal size Mousse and
a white move steps in front of you.
Do you release that Arrow? They got to
shoot that light Mousse in a stupid face.
It's,
it's totally legal.
I don't like the way he
looks. So good size moves. Oh,
we just couldn't sign his mood.
Just going to shoot the Black Moose now,
fuck a light moves around. Moves lives
matter. I don't discriminate white.
I've never shot. The thing is, man,
here's the thing about animal rights
activists and people that are nutty about
animals, they get, what this is is
a genetic anomaly. It's not like a,
this is a specific breed. Right?
It's not out by no though.
It's not an albino. Apparently it's just
got some weird genetic, uh, anomaly.
One of a hundred. Yeah. There's a
hundred of them. So what is it like,
see what it is. If it says,
scroll up a little bit,
I think it says what the genetic
mutation is. Yeah. See it's a,
for coloring is a genetic
mutation and it's not an albino,
not an albino.
Unlike a,
like all white animals I heard that
tastes like vanilla. They taste good dude.
You, you know how to light one that you
never even see anyone that's it. Same.
Same Shit. Same on the inside. It's
like white people. It's all the same.
Once you get look at that,
wow. It's crazy. Another, some,
some people have the string coloring
might be another sign of a shore to
becoming apocalypse. That damn. And
you see a hoard of White Mousse.
Yeah. It was only a hundred of them
though. I wouldn't tell anybody.
I'll tell you one thing. If I did
kill that, I'd keep my mouth shut.
I wouldn't tell people they'd get
too mad even if it didn't matter.
Like if you find a bear,
okay. Like there's um, a
black bear if you're hunting.
But first of all,
if you're hunting black bear,
people get mad at you
anyway cause killing a bear.
Cause then on round bears they think
the bears are extinct or this is a very
short loan beers
depending where you're at.
So many barriers that they're
all cannibals. They eat
each other. That's a fact.
Yeah. The cubs, the cubs like crazy,
including the females will eat their own.
Tam was saying he has to take out the
big older ones cause they'll fuck up all
the cup.
Yeah.
It's actually better for the population
to take out the big males because the
big males eat carbs like w when we
were there. Oh Wow. He's white deer.
Moose. I'm going to, those
are a little baby white moves.
Pigs run off in my car.
They're cute as shit.
Oh they're adorable. The twins are
likely less than a month old show.
Cute cuties,
little cuties that you'd get and there's
a mama big mama is going to achieve.
Will fuck with your world.
They're different than any other
ungulates in that they're real aggressive.
Like a moose will chase you down and
beat your fucking ass. Super Dangerous.
A deer is not likely going to do that.
They've done it before. Ah, fuck it.
The elk might stab you really
with those horns you get,
you get a little cocky when he's Horny,
you talk blocking and elk. Oh yeah.
That's when the crazy, that's rule
number one. They will fuck you up.
They have swords grown out
of their head. See, I'm,
I'm definitely doing a hunt like
that. Some dangerous where, hey,
like I got to watch my ps and qs
like we were hunting like baby fond.
I can't fuck with you guys. I told Cam,
this man has to be something dangerous.
I'm down. Okay, well dear. I mean,
if they did want to fuck you up with
those things, they could stab you.
But the thing is they're, they're prey.
I mean, this is what they are in nature.
They eat grass and they get preyed upon.
They are the food source of mountain
lions and Wolves and countless bears and
countless other animals.
I mean that's just what they are.
They're beautiful while they're alive.
It's not like you should
somehow or another, you know,
diminish their existence.
But that's a prey animal. That's
why they're here. That's why they,
I mean in the system that they're
in the ECO system. Yeah. Yeah.
We didn't create it this their
and their Goddamn Trisha.
So I had some access deer for down
last night. I had access to it.
But when you posted was I get so hungry,
so good.
I've been to the girl up blatant.
That in my opinion is like the most,
if you can get to Hawaii [inaudible]
if you can get to Hawaii,
that's the most ethical place to hunt
because they don't have any predators.
So they have to kill these animals.
So they have like some insane number of,
of deer on Lanai. They have a axis
deer on Maui. They have them on a few.
I think Molokai has him too, cause
there's no predators, predators, none.
So the only predators or people,
so they actually bring over snipers to
take out some of the deer to keep the
population numbers down because
if the population gets too high,
what happens is these deer start getting
disease. They start, you know, they, they,
they run out of food to eat.
The good thing about Hawaii
too is there's so much growth,
like so much plant growth they
can like crazy level. I love it.
You are there for your birthday. We're
what'd you do for your birthday? Nothing.
What a Disneyland took the kids to
Disneyland. Just some weird shit.
My family, Kim Haines is family. That's
cool. Disneyland had a good time. Yeah,
I don't, I don't, I'm
not a big a party guy.
She was still at a birthday part of had
your family speak into a video and it'll
be a good idea.
Right?
Still a French press do that
anyway. Yeah. I'm not a big
birthday day then it's just like,
I don't want to be the center
of attention like that.
It's ironic as that sounds because
most of what I do you want to be in the
center of attention at some
will walk, right? Yeah.
But it just seems like he's just weird.
Yeah.
I'd rather just do a set.
Have a nice dinner. Yeah.
So went to Disneyland or
with the Guardians of Galaxy
ride. God Damn. It's fun.
I love it. So good. I thought, oh my God,
they're going to bit make tower of
terror better. Oh, that's right.
How chairs my feet. Right of all time.
They shit. I'm better now. Really?
It's better. I'm not going to galaxy.
Well, I really haven't seen it.
Go to the galaxies. Right.
He'd never saw that movie.
It's a fun fucking movie then.
I haven't seen Bart too,
but I saw apart when you finally saw
La Alien Covenant, who loved how good.
I've loved old Jimmy. Loved it. A lot
of these people that didn't like it.
My favorite alien get out of my life.
People didn't like that.
You've got some shit advice.
It was brilliant. Yeah.
What'd you say is a bad movie?
Alien Covenant. Oh yeah. Click
do. I was grumpy. I was crunk
for that alien. I, I was,
I loved it. I loved swear to God when the
movie guys, I stood up standing ovation,
slow clap. Everyone else sit down. I
love when they made the AI guy gave him,
I don't want to say too much spoiler
for a grip. It doesn't matter.
Some people out there don't have a time.
God Damn it.
It's been out for how many months you're
going to have to like tune out now
folks,
because we're going to talk about it.
Seen Alien Covenant that came out
seven months ago. Go ahead and fucked.
He has to eat it is to eat it. All
right. You do have to tell the story.
The one alien, that hybrid
alien. Ooh Dude. It was fun.
I liked the fact that that the AI guy
like they, they cut out as creativity.
Right? He started getting
weird guilt. So it makes sense.
I give you give artificial intelligence
the the need and the ability to create.
So, but this movie, it went prometheus's
first, then this, right? Yeah. Yeah.
It was like 10 years after Prometheans
yeah, atheists. I liked that too.
What was the movie with the alien?
They named him Calvin. You don't,
I'm talking about and a Ryan we
add, fuck yeah, I like that too.
I've watched that on every, and I
watched them prop that those movies is,
there's cut the shit scenes.
Like when the guy that you know life one
where they're playing with it and they
try these experiments with it and the
shock electric like, hey come on man,
you doing this out in space. Don't you
want to bring this back to Earth for you?
Start fucking with it.
It's an hour secured laboratory.
We can't cause you do that.
And then look,
if we brought that bitch back to
Earth then you know what I'm saying?
I thought that movie was so fucking good
doing things like zapping it and trying
to like stimulate.
They thought he was dead though.
Remember until the his
abdomen, he went, Oh yeah,
that movie was so tense.
He was scary as shit was scary.
You know the problem was the gold.
They gave him a little bit of a
CGI face and I was like, come on.
I didn't like that either. Like that
demon face. Nah Man, I don't need that.
Keep Him Calvin. I liked how
they called him Calvin. Yeah,
because they couldn't make it to demonic
cause then it would be alien cherished,
the most demonic. That thing is the
most amount of the thing. So scary. Oh,
it's awesome. God, I loved that movie.
Tongue thing comes out. All this.
I like all a slobber and shit that
comes out of it's mouth to it.
This big giant fucking bug head dude.
Have you been to the theater?
It's right off. It's in
Westwood there. I picked,
now you're talking, you get steaks.
You can get chicken tenders.
I mean you gotta be off your Diet.
Where is it? It's a write off of uh, uh,
Wilshire, Wilshire, and it's called,
I pick like Sydney apolis that kind of
shared kind of this huge less now at the
VIP. It's going to cost about $60 get in
the door. That's the way to do it though.
That's it. Sign. Ooh, where's that? That's
it. Ooh, it's a small theater too. Yeah,
you did take the community, take your
wifey there. That's the move, man.
Less people.
They have all alcohol drinks,
who stakes like everything
man. Like it. I like it.
And you can look down upon the people who
didn't buy the VIP tickets. It's cool.
And judge out and walk by you. Oh,
so there's people below you there.
I have regular sex and you're like,
get out of here peasants. Move on.
Peasant stole. Look at me. What if they
talk? Enjoy the movie pass down below.
You know they're angry about their
position in society. They might.
And in the movie theater, I snitch on him.
You can ask Niche, which I'm right away.
Oh, excuse me. Not false ma'am. Ma'Am.
Do you know that there's a system that
you can get for your house where it
downloads movies as they come out
and you can watch brand new movies.
I need that chance.
They come out cause we're the kid like it,
like Annabel the new Annabel Kim. I love
scary movies. Like did you see it now?
I want, I'm dying to see it. That knew.
You seen that new it trailer shit.
Your pants scary. It looks Kevin
September. Here's how he's moving.
People are getting pissed off.
I think it's run by Netflix or the same
guy that started Netflix started this
sort of thing. It's been available
for a while at 50 bucks a month,
but now it's down to 10 bucks a month.
There's some weird catch.
This some catches to it like it's only
for two d versions and then like you have
to pay
for a ticket or something and then he
get paid back. There's some weird cat.
I would pay like $100 a month
to watch movies at my house.
This is not at your house though?
Yeah.
This is different than what
they was talking about. Sorry.
Let's do something totally different.
Oh,
this is just cheap movie tickets
that people are mad about. Yeah,
but the house things not cheap.
The house thing is a system you get,
I think it's like $50,000 and once
you have it installed in your house,
then you can watch movies as they come
out and they're on like a hard drive.
Such a movie buff dude. If you had like
a home theater. That's what I'm saying.
Having a home theater is closed movies
cause with a kid it stuff get the
babysitter. I see mood like fuck
man, I just saw like star wars.
You know like it takes a while.
Like I'm like I can't wait for that to
come out on DVD stuff. Yeah. This thing
you can't even see what movies are. I
think that's exactly it. You pay for it.
So I can't even find
most movies that are out.
I think that is exactly it and
it's very expensive. Like I said,
I think it's like $50,000
and it just comes with the service to
provide the movie. Yeah, I think you just,
it's like a hard drive and you download
whatever the movie is that you want to
see and you can watch it.
I feel like you shouldn't do that now
because with technology is coming so fast
and, and like Netflix are gone. You know,
big movie stars like Will Smith and
these guys and Adam Sandler doing these
Netflix deals so you don't have to go.
The theater is kind of fingerprint reader,
finger swipe with liveliness detection,
liveliness live ness mean someone.
Lots of cut your fucking hand off and
have a dead hand that they used to start
up your screen.
Let's take your fingerprint on a piece
of paper or a dead hand will live ness
queer just like you see lack of right
up there on their fingerprints on it.
What kind of a person wants to kill
someone so they can see pirates of the
Caribbean? Oh Dude, I would,
I might kill a bitch. See,
see the new edit my house. I'd slice
one's finger off at home. Dude,
how great would that be?
I don't like Jim Ready going
out and I want to chill at home.
My undies watched all the new movies.
He's a real problem is other people when
they can't keep it together and they
start answering phones talking.
I've been at so many movie theaters where
people start talking to so annoying.
I screw this one will be theater.
It was a little urban take that.
How do you want a little urban and then
the move to homeboy in front of me just
on the phone the whole time
and people are like, God.
And so I go bro off the phone,
man, and it keeps going.
Puts up his finger like this. I'm
like, oh, it keeps going. Go Bro.
Moussaka Gopro off your fucking phone.
It turns around goes wait till the
movie's over. I've been some fights, man.
I think I can fight and I the whole movie,
all I could think of, I'm like, alright,
what am I going to do here? I got my girl
here. What is he with all those people,
they all look similar. If guests were
drift, what am I going to, Durban,
am I going to get jumped?
Like how is this? I couldn't,
I couldn't tell you what movie I
saw in fucks your whole experience.
I'm just balls deep in popcorn.
I'm gonna fuck carbon carbon up.
Car bloated carbon movie gets done.
He didn't say shit.
Ah, fuck the whole movie up
though. We should have said
something. I was stressed.
Mm. Just the whole, every middle man,
probably three, four years ago, I think.
I know I'm thinking if I was you,
if I could remote control your body
and my cove there smack me in the head.
But what happens if there's a
bunch band you were with your girl,
you know what I'm saying? It depends
on how many got, but yeah, that's,
it is a very,
very rude and disrespectful and
be on your phone on Instagram.
Like I can see your phone,
you're on Facebook and what the fuck
you're in the movies. He's a dummy dummy.
You're a dummy there.
God damn addicted to their phones.
Like do you know a few people have the
ability to sit through a fucking podcast
without looking at their phones? You know
how to do it. But a lot of my guests,
I see them checking their phones,
checking their phones, texting, hold on.
Just kind of Texas. So disrespectful. You
do that if you're on sports center. Yeah.
Right. Especially not now. You
know at this in this day and age,
but for some people the requirement of
an hour or two or in a podcast three
without checking the phone, impossible,
chill out. You're not that busy folks.
It's not that. It's they're addicts,
they're straight up junkies.
They're getting that little tweak,
that little rush of anticipation right
that down. If they get an email or text,
they say literally we don't, and we don't
even know how addicted the phones are,
but people,
their brains are coming in addicted to it.
Just to the sensation of feeling it and
the colors and mentions and Instagram
and dms. And what's your my phone real
quick. Yeah. Let me check my phone.
It just seems like we're talking
about my mouth to salvation.
It's never as fun as talking to friends,
but you go to a restaurant,
you'll see five people on their phones,
not even looking at each other.
I hate that shit.
When you're hanging out with a friend
and they're on their phone all the time,
it's brutal. It's like, dude, I be
here, can be here, but your phone down,
put your phone down. There's
some restaurants, they take
your phone at the door,
you know that fuck. And there's some
that give 20 bucks. Then there's some,
if you don't use your phone, you get 25%
off. If you don't use your phone at all.
So your camera's overhead. I don't
know how gang checking. Gotcha. No, no,
no. You're in the restaurant
and you checked it. No,
we've got a trick to when I got up
from the table now it doesn't count.
Don't get the deal. My man, I was taking
a shit. I didn't have anything to do.
You can't check it. He's
still, you checked in the
restaurant in the restaurant.
I don't know how it works.
Taking p fake shit so he could check
your Facebook took a fake shit just to
check your Facebook addicted son.
Yeah. And people are super addicted.
You and Joey d has a pretty
good about calling. Oh yeah.
I called [inaudible] and I take
so much of my sometimes you know,
sometimes I don't know cause you're busy.
So now I'm busy.
So you got a tax when you texting novels
now we went back and forth. There was a,
we had a question, I'm like, okay, I got
to hear this. Yeah, we had a talk. Yeah,
it's exhausting. Yeah man.
There's some people that just,
they what for whatever reason
are tethered to the hip.
And then there's some people that
decide they can't use it at all.
So they just go straight cell phone.
Like, like Putin phone flip phone. Yeah.
Sorry. Ari Aziz Ansari as he's
Ansari's gone totally off the Internet.
I was watching some video
with an intern or a no,
it was a reading of vice article,
I think it was vice.
They interviewed them and they were
asking about it. He, he is an offline,
he's killing, got rid of his social
media, really got rid of all his shit.
He doesn't do anything. So
did uh, ed Sheeran cause he,
he appeared on game of Thrones and he got
such backlash. He was just, you know, he,
he stopped doing it.
How many book cons?
You have thicker skin flake
off line for a few days, Bro.
But people are going to use it for
what it is, you know, put these trolls.
Who gives a fuck everything.
Everything.
There's nothing that you do to get away
from that. Nothing. It is what it is.
Go to Kevin Hart's post and
it's like fuck you Kevin Hart.
Kevin Hart does to many people and
everybody having access to everybody being
able to communicate with you.
If you just decide to swim in that river
and you wonder why he got poisoned.
Yeah, I agree. The promise with
your kids, like even now my son,
he wants grabbed my phone and
you don't do it like just,
he's not going to Twitter and
checking dams and Dick pics,
but he's like scrolling
through everything. Just cause
the stimulation. Oh yeah.
What was like your daughters and
how old are they? Seven and nine.
They have phones. No. Do your
nine year old does it? No.
No, she didn't shut the school. The,
I wonder if you give kids phones,
you let them see beheading videos.
You're letting them tune
them on the latest news.
They can see that car
run over those people,
that white power rally and all that
shit a kid can see and they're gonna see
their friends going to tell them about it.
Just think of the shit that you look
at. I mean, think of the shit that I,
every day I'm posting
some new ridiculous video.
Someone doing something stupid and some
brain damage could like keep an eye on
your kids.
Hit ninth grade is nine years old is
what grade third and they're going into
fourth wait til she gets to sixth grade.
Yeah.
I think like you'd have to be
the nerd in school or some,
sometimes they didn't have the iPads
to write notes and shit. Oh yeah,
for sure. And those things
go online. Yeah. Yeah.
It's one of those things where you got
to wonder at what point is it okay to
give it to them and how much do you
regulate it and how much you do.
You do it by example. You know, if,
if you're at home with your kids and
like stay off the phone kids and you're
just like constantly checking on,
then they're going to be pissed at you.
There should be no phones
between whatever, you know,
especially dinner time.
So it's going to be a beast,
man.
What do we do with a big thing
we do in my house, a lot of art,
a lot of arts school constantly,
constantly.
Like they're always painting
and drawing and doing shit.
If you give kids that opportunity to do
something and then they get like in a
pattern of doing it all the time
where they're not, you know,
their stimulation doesn't cut
TV, phone watch TV or no, yeah,
we let them watch TV.
We don't keep it from them,
but we don't let them watch it all
day. Yeah. So it's, I think that like,
I think especially creativity's important
for kids because the more they realize
they can make things.
Even if you could just make something
out of paper machete or something where
you're writing something, you
know, something that didn't exist,
you like my daughter writes stories,
like a story that didn't exist.
Now the story's written like you wrote it,
you created it.
Like you realize you read stories,
you can also write him, you know,
paintings and make a painting,
make a drawing.
And the more you realize
you can create things,
it's my thought that it opens up your
idea of what's possible for your whole
life. You can create things in your
life. You don't have to bank on anyone.
You can create businesses,
you can create a career.
You could figure out like how to
work hard at something and create it.
I also think it's really good for their
little brains to like make things. Yeah.
For me it's weird because every
morning I live across from a school to
elementary school. Yesterday was
there the first day of school.
So there's all these parents
dropping off the kids.
I was watching the kids play outside.
I walked my son every morning.
I was thinking, God, how the fuck
is he going to make friends like us?
All the clicks. I've never thought
about ever, ever in my life of that.
How this little Duke and I make friends
[inaudible] if he doesn't make friends,
stay on me. All the friends
work, not, you can't be the nerd.
He can't, he can't be paranoid
and say, give me 10 pushups.
Even when they don't make friends
that that's good to, you know,
realize like what's wrong? Like why
aren't you making friends? Like what?
Just your behavior accordingly.
It won't,
don't be the introverted kid who's in
balls deep into the comics maybe or fine
are the ones who also or yeah,
I agree or do and then,
and then take over the world
like Hollywood, you know,
but it's the first time it ever crossed
my mind. I saw all these kids playing.
I thought, AH, why don't, if he doesn't
like France, I got to deal with that.
What are you going to do if your son
gets older and he is like sort of
introverted, kind of nerdy and you
see some predatory bitch move in.
What if your son becomes like some super
successful producer type character and
you see some printed,
oh my God.
Predatory Coyote type woman
just not to Leech runs him.
Tells him what to do. Oh,
oh my God. You see it.
You go with the house and you're like,
son, you can't let her tell you that.
Just nothing. You can do the power
of the pussy. There's nothing and do,
do you know that feeling
that you have when a friend,
when you see a friend is
getting taken over? Like, like
almost like I go like, uh,
a pod person, you know, like one of
them night of the living dead? No, not,
not as Avatar. What does
that fucking movie? They, a
vision of the body snatchers.
Remember hod was under the bed.
Never saw the movie. No, dude. Well,
there's a couple versions of it.
There's a really,
really old version for like the 50. It's
the new one that, well, there's three.
There's a Donald Sutherland version,
which is I think want to see like the 70s,
which is excellent.
A young Jeff gold blooms in that movie.
It's a great movie and it's creepy,
scary and you know,
like good special effects for the time,
for the time.
And then there's a more recent one with
Jennifer Tilly I think is in it or meg
Tilly. Meg Tilly. Jennifer Tilly
is sister and their paws. Yeah.
Yeah. What it is is while
you're sleeping, um, it,
it somehow or another like the fibers
get ahold of you. Like it climbs up.
Like if the pods like near the bed,
it gets a hold of you and touches you
and then it puts you to sleep and starts
replicating you underneath the bed.
So like while while you're sleeping,
it's like draining your
body and replicating you.
And then in the morning you're dead.
You're like a dry hos alien is underneath.
Yeah.
So this is Donald
Sutherland as he's asleep.
This thing he had was taking over and
recreating him and he woke up before it
was too late. Dude, it was adult
movie. Let's Kiefer Sutherland.
His dad is out of even know
that no one knew our Keith.
That's what fucked up dad was
Donald Sutherland. That's,
that's Jack Bauer. Right.
If you, uh, if you grow up in your
dad's a famous actor and your,
you become an actor yourself, you gotta be
fucked up. Yeah. It'd be a little weird.
That's the end. Oh, that must be the
new one right there. That poster.
What is that one? Invasion of the body
snatchers. Yeah. [inaudible] 78. No,
that must be the 78 version.
Cause it the newer ones. Oh,
the newer one is below that in green.
See it in green down there. We'll show.
That's the really old one.
That's the 1950s one. Ooh Dude.
It looks pretty sweet. There was one
more that, uh, happened with meg Tilly.
I don't remember what year, but I want
to say it's like maybe late nights.
Don't recreate it already.
Yeah, there she is
based at the body statutes.
The dork report.
Bodysnatchers oh, it's just
called body snatchers. It's
brilliant. Oh really? Yeah.
I'll check that shit out. Um, do you know
what movie was? That's the porn version.
Body starts. You don't move. It was dope.
I watched on the plane with
19 1983 that was pretty good,
but it's one of those things like you
don't even really make those things so
many times. What was dope? I watched that
movie with Ben Affleck where he gets it.
He moved to Tampa. He's like
a mafia gangster moves to
table this accountant. No,
no, no, no. See I thought it was the
county I was, I was taking some pills.
I was a little out of it. I thought it
was the counting and I was like, what the,
he counted the accountant and I was like,
that's not this. It was something else.
That shit was so good.
Really? Yeah. He's like,
he's involved with the mob and
they wanted me to go run the,
the Tampa Bay wing of it. So he goes
down there. Oh fuck. It was good, Huh?
Oh Man. It was fucking classic. Well
has it? Yeah. Hi. Where are you?
You're high as a kite.
I might've been fucking ambien and shit.
They don't work on me. Really. I took
him in Austria and people are like,
only take one. I was like, I'm not that
sleepy. So I pop the three of them.
I was fucking one eye open just
like Ben Affleck's the best ever.
Live by gas.
6.4 on rotten tomatoes.
Fucking haters are my down
after you fucking hate.
Why do people hate on athletic?
He's goodwill. Hunting.
Seems like a Douche though.
How dare you ever see his argument with
Sam Harris on the bill Maher show now a
habit and a very uninformed huge mistake.
He argued with Sam Harris about the what?
What's in Islam?
Well hey listen,
I don't want to say stay in your lane.
I'm all over the place. But
with Ben Affleck, Sam Harris,
he'd never seen it. No,
it's hilarious cause Affleck
doesn't know what to do.
So he goes full social justice warrior
and starts calling Sam Harris are racist.
It's gross. You're so gross. It's so
racist. What? Saying it's so gross.
And then Sam Harris is like super
calm this. He's the problem.
Like you can't like yell and argue with
Harris because he will never go there.
It makes you look in,
it makes you look super amateur,
especially when he starts spouting
off facts on explaining the,
we were talking about an ideology.
Did Ben Affleck go on there to debate him?
I think what it was is he was getting
ready for Batman. This is my personal,
uh, belief. Uh, it has no basis, in
fact, and it's just pure speculation.
He was on steroids. He was on
steroids getting ready for Batman.
You've got jack for Batman.
He got jacked.
And I think when you get jacked like that,
get a little fucking testing.
He had, he had no, he had
no data. This fuck you bro.
About he tried to sling a little Dana.
It's Sam Harris,
and he just got, just got run
over. Oh my God. What do you think?
Kings go run over. And everybody was
Super Mad at him afterwards. He was like,
oh yeah, online. They got torn apart and
they just handled it very poorly. I see.
I don't get the hate, well,
obviously he fucked up there,
but I don't get the hate with Ben
Affleck. He makes good movies, but Gili.
All right, you're fucking to see that. And
they go, Ooh, that's the real you. Well,
that's it, but is it 3 million? I at
him, Rose Lane on steroids. Could be,
could be.
Couldn't be.
I would think that I've never
seen him behave like that before,
and he definitely got
jacked for that movie.
And when you're 45 years old
or whatever he is, you don't,
you just don't get jacked. Like,
no, you don't put on muscle.
I don't put it on normal.
It's not normal you,
unless you're on some radical supplements,
which if Hollywood called me,
it was a kid. We to be Bruce
Wayne. I'm going to get on that,
but Gotham city cycle,
I'm going to get on some of that
Clenbuterol to lower my body fat. Oh,
I'm calling fucking, I'll
release the hounds. I'm a fuck.
They won't even need a mask. It's
just going to be that yet. Um,
he gained 20 pounds, 228
pounds total, got down to 7.9%.
Body fat.
Ben Affleck's trainer,
Walter Norton Junior talks
about Ben Affleck's eight.
During the day's filming the town,
he lost 12 pounds for the town.
He was stronger and every lift
hate Walter Norton Junior.
How would you tell us the cycle he's on?
Cattell she the truth
thought about testosterone.
But if your photo of him with
his shirt off at 7.9% body fat,
because I think I'm calling bullshit on
that. You know how low that is? Very low.
He never got that ripped.
He wasn't even as ripped as a,
the last Batman Christian Bale. Christian
Bale coat hanger though. You know,
he's real thin now. He got jacked
and he's, he's always thin.
Um, real low body fat no more. Yeah.
I don't think he's an ectomorph.
Mesomorph no, I don't know. Well,
let's look at him. Look at him next,
but I think you're wrong on that. Wow.
Let's see. You got a good
picture. Pull it up so we can say,
show us what do we got
here? No, that's not good.
Shirtless Atlas or him in a tank top.
That him right.
He's fucking just one right there.
The Rock. Oh, that's the Ra.
That's the rocks body. The,
my daddy's Jack. That's the
rock. Oh, that's fine. Yeah,
that's the tattoos. He'll go up to
the one right there. That's superman.
Is it a dance? Superman. Oh, searing.
Mass belly. So Brian's jacked.
Ben Affleck is kind of sorted. Jack
put Ben Affleck shirtless. That's,
that's Ben Affleck. A fucking dad
mode though. That's not him shirtless.
What's that word there?
That's still superman.
That's at the BC.
Not Buying it.
Not Buying it. I don't give a
fuck if that was 10 years ago.
You don't let me stop.
Let me stop this right now.
That is so not 7.9% body fat.
Go back.
Go back to those pictures
of him right there.
That is not even remotely seventeen's.
That's why.
That's not more like 20 right? Yeah. Let
me just an Argo. Okay. Different movie.
Good upper right hand corner. Upper right
hand corner. No, that's not him son.
That's the wolf from a true
blood. Diabetes. Hello?
Why are they lying here? Ben Affleck's
has ripped sexy. You Jack. No,
Chris Pratt got jacked.
I don't know if that's real.
That's been Africa that Chris
Pratt. That's, see, that's
not really that jacked.
There was a scene of him in, that's
how it used to be. He used to be fat.
He looked pretty. Looks pretty good.
Yeah, but that's not like the rock jacked.
Jesus Christ. It's fake.
All these are fake pictures.
Who was that guy?
American Dad.
Him and Batman suit son's got a
bullshit suit on. So there's, oh,
go to homeboy there. Yes. Jake
Gyllenhaal. Oh yeah, he did get jacked.
You know who else got really Jake Gillen?
Damn homeboy got shot. 7% body fat. Yes.
That's what 7% looks like. Go back to him
now you go into gay porn. Jamie, stop it.
I'm just seeing who end have an Affleck
or see if it's a guy jerk off to now
he's fucking super, just like 10%
the San Francisco is so unheard of.
That looks like a guy was fighting
in the UFC right now, correct? Yeah.
Jay and walls with my face. Yeah.
See that's the kind of dedication.
I don't know if Ben have like, dude,
get down to that goodwill hunting.
He never saw that and I've never
seen that. That's some shit.
Now go to Christian Bale.
See much more Jack.
There's some good pictures of Christian
Bale jacked type in Christian Bale. Jack,
that's pretty good right
there. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
Now he's, he just looked more like
a guy who could really fuck you up.
Then I feel like Ben Affleck looks
true. No disrespect, no disrespect.
Like right there. Upper left hand
car. All right. Ryan Reynolds.
First team all by fucking
jacked right there is,
I mean that looks like a
real Batman. Yeah. Oh my God.
That's the machinist.
That was like one of the worst movies he
ever did in terms of like the reception
and gone. How many people watched it?
It wasn't bad. It was really weird.
But the difference between being the
skinny guy in the right hand side,
which was like him dying.
I mean he essentially starved himself,
almost a death and then a few months
later he's the guy on the left.
That's him in the movie. Fuck yeah.
He played a guy with narcolepsy.
They couldn't sleep, didn't eat.
Look how skinny he got, man.
He's all good of an actor. Is that
fucking, I don't know if that's acting.
That's just being a psycho that's
dedicated to get crashed into your car.
You craft a starving to death.
You're really good at it. I mean,
that's the mental willpower.
It's a, Oh yeah, for sure.
But it's really bad for your body.
Oh, and it's not good enough.
It's not good enough of a movie too.
I'll tell you who got jacked was
Ryan Reynolds. Oh, he's jacked. Yeah.
For Blade two. Oh. Oh yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Yeah.
But why wouldn't you do that if
you're playing up a fake character?
I don't get why you wouldn't do a nice
cycle. Oh yeah, for sure. Or you do the,
uh, yeah, he was jacked.
Or you do the Girard thing.
What's that guy's name from 300 butler?
Yeah. They just CGI the fuck out of you.
[inaudible] story with that.
We're 300. They're, you know,
they're making a movie.
Everyone's doing crossfit nonstop doing
the spark workouts and Butler is not
showing up. And they're like, what the
fuck, man? He's like, I'm not doing this.
I don't want to do that. He goes,
just tell me when I have to be ready.
I will be ready by any means
necessary. Like really? He's like,
I got this and the didn't do what
everyone else didn't came fucking
hi.
Killed it. Yeah. Well it probably,
well, the thing about the,
is that really what his body actually
looked like, wow, but now he's fucking,
he was in there like,
what the fuck?
He was super jacked and
then he let himself go. Wow.
It's hard to maintain that.
Yeah, that's, he can't mean
how much is it? It's real.
How much is what he really looked like?
Oh, go upper left hand corner. Yeah.
Was that okay? That's, that's more
realistic. Now there's even a better one.
Keeps you look at it.
Go to that one set of tits on them.
Then I'm so go.
Imagine if you're a girl and you're think
you're fucking 300 and you get to that
God damn and you feel that a hundred pads
resting on the top of your ass while I
Bang
behind
this year.
Hold up girl.
Breast thug is a spartan life.
Holy Step fucker off to movie.
God, you go halfway limp because
you doing coke all night.
Just the worst night of your life.
I'm just going to do when they
come for you. Brennan sharp.
We're gonna get out of here and get
another podcast. We do. That was fun. Man.
Flew by. Three hours. Three
hours, fucking flew by
of the definitely.
So
Mayweather, Mcgregor, we'd probably
made some MMA sites. Awesome headlines.
Do you have any, any
prediction on it? You can't.
What do you think in your
heart of hearts is what I like?
I like shocking results.
A shocking result is
Mayweather comes out there,
underestimates Conor McGregor and Connor
puts him at the fucking end of the
rainbow. He's, he's dancing with
the leprechauns and a pot of gold.
How did I get here?
Cause he's in fucking dreamland
cause he face planted. That's,
that's the exciting result.
The exciting result is Conor McGregor
becomes the greatest athlete the world's
ever known and the most famous guy of all
time and a MMA wins. I agree with you.
All right. That's it man. Love you.
That was awesome. You're the best.
How can I be the best
when you're the best?